learn how to build your own large
language model from scratch this course
goes into the data handling math and
Transformers behind large language
models Elia Arledge created this course
he will help you gain a deep
understanding of how llms work and how
they can be used in various applications
so let's get started welcome to intro to
language modeling in this course you're
going to learn a lot of crazy stuff okay
I'm just going to give you a heads up
it's going to be a lot of crazy stuff we
learn here however it will not be
insanely hard I don't expect you have
any any experience in calculus or linear
algebra a lot of courses out there do
assume that but I will not
we're going to build up from square one
we're going to take baby steps when it
comes to new fundamental concepts in
math and machine learning and we're
going to take larger steps once things
are fairly clear and they're sort of
easy to figure out that way we don't
take forever just taking baby steps
through every little concept this course
is inspired by Andre karapati's building
a GPT from scratch lecture
so shout out to him and
yeah we don't assume you have any
experience maybe three months of python
experience uh just so the syntax is sort
of familiar and you can
you're able to follow along that way but
uh no matter how smart you are how quick
you learn
the willingness to put in the hours is
the most important because this material
you won't normally come across
so as long as you're able to put in that
constant effort uh push through these
lectures even if it's hard take a quick
break grab a snack whatever you need to
do grab some water water is very
important and yeah hopefully you can
make it to the end of this
you can do it since it's free code Camp
everything will be local computation
nothing in the room of paid data sets or
cloud computing
we'll be scaling the data to about 45
gigabytes for the entire training data
set so have 90 reserved so we can
download the initial 45 and then convert
it to an easier to work with 45.
so yeah if you don't actually have 90
gigabytes reserved that's totally fine
you can just download a different data
set and sort of follow the same data
pipeline that I do in this video
through the course you may see me switch
between Mac OS and windows the code
still works all the same both operating
systems and I'll be using a tool called
SSH it's a server that I can connect
from my MacBook to my Windows PC that
I'm recording on right now
and that will allow me to execute run
build whatever do anything coding
related uh command prompt related on my
MacBook so I'll be able to do everything
on there that I can my Windows computer
it'll just look a little bit different
for the recording so
uh why am I creating this course well
like I said before a lot of beginners
they don't have the fundamental
knowledge like calculus linear algebra
to help them get started or accelerate
their learning in this space so I intend
to build up from baby steps and then
larger steps when things are fairly
simple to work with
and I'll use logic analogies and
step-by-step examples to help consent
conceptualize rather than just throw
tons of formula at you
so with that being said let's go ahead
and jump in to the good stuff so in
order to develop this project step by
step we're going to use something called
Jupiter notebooks and you can sort of
play with these in the Anaconda prompt
or at least launch them from here so
Anaconda prompt is just great for
anything machine learning related so
make sure to have this installed I will
link a video in the description so that
you can sort of set this up and install
it step-by-step guide in there so we can
do from this point is sort of just set
up our project and initialize everything
so I'm going to do is just head over
into my directory that I want
just gonna be
python testing we're going to make a
directory free code camp gbt
course and then from this point uh we're
gonna go and make a virtual environment
so virtual environment
it will
and initially in your desktop you will
have just all of your python libraries
all your dependencies there just
floating around and what the virtual
environment does is it just sort of
separates that so you have this isolated
environment over here and you can just
play around with this however you want
and it's completely separate so that
won't really
cross with all of the global libraries
that you have all the ones that just
affect the system when you're not in a
virtual environment if that makes sense
so we're going to go ahead and set that
up right now by using python Dash M and
then we're going to go venv for virtual
EnV and then Cuda so the reason why we
say Cuda here is because later when we
try to accelerate our learning or the
models learning
we're going to need to use gpus gpus are
going to accelerate this a ton and
basically Cuda is just that little
feature in the GPU that lets us do that
so we're going to make our environment
called cuda I'm going to go and press
enter it's going to do that for it's
going to take a few seconds so now that
that's done we can go ahead and do Cuda
and we're just going to basically
activate this environment so we can
start developing in it
we're going to go backslash and we're
going to go Scripts
and then activate so now you can see it
says Cuda base so we're in Cuda and then
secondary base so it's going to
prioritize Cuda
so from this point we can actually start
installing some stuff some libraries
here so we can go pip3
install mat plot lib
numpy we're going to use p-y-l-m-z-a
l z m a and then
what are some other ones we're going to
do
ipy kernel this is for the actual
Jupiter notebooks and being able to
bring the Cuda virtual environment into
those notebooks so that's why that's
important and then just the actual
Jupiter notebook feature so go ahead and
press enter those are going to install
that's going to take a few seconds to do
so what might actually happen is you'll
get a build error with p y l z m a which
is a compression algorithm and don't
quote me on this but I'm pretty sure
it's based in C plus plus so you
actually need some build tools for this
and you can get that with uh Visual
Studio build tools so what you're you
might see you might see a little error
and basically go to that website and
you're going to get this right here so
just go ahead and download build tools
so it's going to download here you're
going to click on that it's gonna it's
gonna set up
and then
you're going to go ahead and click
continue
and then at this point you can go ahead
and click modify if you see this here
and then you might get to a little
workloads section here so once you're at
workloads that's good what you're going
to make sure is that you have these two
checked off right here just make sure
that you have these two
um I'm not sure what desktop
particularly does it might help but it's
just kind of good to have some of these
build tools on your PC anyways even for
future projects so
um just get these two for now that'll be
good and then you can click modify over
here if you wanted to modify it just
like that and then you should be good to
rerun that command so from this point
what we can actually do
is we're going to install torch and
we're not just going to do it by using
pip install
torch
we're not going to do it like this what
we're actually going to do is we're
going to use a separate command
and this is going to install Cuda with
our
torch so it's going to install the Cuda
extension which will allow us to utilize
the GPU
so it's just this Command right here and
if you want to find like a good command
to use what you can do is go to the pi
torch docs uh just go to go to get
started and then
you'll be able to see this right here so
we have stable
Windows pip Python then Cuda 11.7 or
11.8 so I just clicked on this
and since we aren't going to be using a
torch Vision or torch audio I basically
just did hip 3 install torch and then
with this index URL for the Cuda 11.8 so
that's pretty much all we're doing there
to install Cuda
it's part of our torch so we can go
ahead and click enter on this
so great we've installed a lot of things
a lot of libraries a lot of setup has
been done already what I want to check
now is just to make sure that our python
version is what we want so python
version 3.10.9 that's great if you're
between 3.9 3.10 3.11 that's perfect so
if you're in between those should be
fine
at this point we can just jump right
into our Jupiter notebook so the command
for that is just Jupiter notebook
spelled like that
look enter
it's going to send us into here
and I've created this little
bigram.ipymb here in my vs code
so
pretty much you need to actually type
some stuff in it and you need to make
sure that it has the IP ynb
extension or else it won't work so if
it's just ip1b and doesn't have anything
in it I can't really read that file for
some reason and yeah so just just make
sure you type some stuff in it open that
in vs code Type like I don't know a
equals three or
Str equals banana I don't care
at this point let's go ahead and pop
into here
so this is what our notebook is going to
look like and we're going to be working
with this quite a bit uh throughout this
course
so
what we're going to need to do next here
is make sure that our virtual
environment is actually inside of our
notebook and make sure that we can
interact with it from this kernel rather
than just through the command prompt so
we're going to go ahead and check here
and I have a virtual environment here
you may not but all we're going to do is
basically go into here we're going to
end this
and all we're going to do
is we're going to go ahead and do python
Dash M and then ipy
kernel install
user
and you'll see why we're doing this in
the second user name equals Cuda this is
from the virtual environment we
initialized before
so that's the name of the virtual
environment and then the display name
how it's actually going to look in the
terminal
is going to be display
we'll just call it
um
Cuda
gbt I don't know that sounds like a cool
name and then we'll go and press enter
just gonna make this environment for us
great installed
good so we can go and run our notebook
again and
we'll see if this changes
so we go ahead and pop into our bigram
again
kernel change kernel boom Cuda gbt let's
click that
sweet
so now we can actually start doing more
and just sort of experimenting with how
the notebooks work and actually how we
can build up this diagram model and sort
of learning how
language models work from scratch so
let's go ahead and do that so before we
jump into this actual code here what I
want to do is
uh Delete all of these good
so now what I'm going to do is just get
a small little data set just very small
for us to work with that we can sort of
try to make a diagram out of something
very small
so what we can do is go to this website
called Project Gutenberg and they
basically just have a bunch of free
books that are uh license under Creative
Commons so we can use all of these for
free
so let's use uh The Wizard of Oz
at the end The Wizard of Oz great
so what we're going to want to do is
just click on Plain text here great
so now I can go Ctrl s to save this and
then we could just go wizard
of Oz
wizard underscore of underscore Oz good
so now what I'm going to do is we should
probably drag this
into
[Music]
we should drag this into
our folder here so I'm just going to pop
that
into there good stuff
did that work sweet so now we have our
Wizard of Oz text in here we can open
that
what we can do is
start of this book okay so we can go
ahead and
let me go down to when it starts
sweet
so maybe we'll just cut it here that'd
be a good place to start just like that
and put a few spaces good
so now we have this book uh we go to the
bottom here just to get rid of some of
this
other licensing stuff which is might get
in the way with our predictions in the
in the context of the entire book
so let's just go down to when that
starts
end of the book okay
Okay so we've gotten all that that is
done
with the illustration there
perfect so now we have this Wizard of Oz
text that we can work with let's close
close that up
233 kilobytes awesome very small size we
can work with this this is great so we
have this wizard of oz.txt file and what
are we going to do with that well we're
going to try to train uh a Transformer
or at least a background language model
on this text so in order to do that we
need to sort of learn how to manage this
text file how to open it Etc
so we're gonna go ahead and open this
I'm gonna do Wizard of Oz
like that and we're gonna open in read
mode and then we're going to use the
encoding
utf-8 just like that so this is the file
mode that you're going to open in uh
there's read mode there's right mode
there's read binary there's write binary
and those are really the only ones we're
going to be boring out uh worrying about
for this video
um
the other ones you can look into in your
spare time if you'd like to uh we're
just gonna using those four for now and
then the encoding is just what type of
character encoding are we using uh
that's pretty much it and we can just
open this as F short for file
I'm gonna go text equals F dot read
I'm just going to read this file stored
in a string variable and then we can you
know we can print and print some stuff
about it so we can go print the length
of
print the length of this text run that
we get the length of the text
um
we could print the
first
uh 200 characters of the text sure so
the first 200 characters great
um so now we know how to you know just
play with characters
um at least just see what the characters
actually look like so now we can do a
little bit more from this point which is
going to be uh encoders and
uh before we get into that what I'm
going to do is put these into a little
vocabulary list that we can work with so
all I'm going to do is I'm going to say
we're going to make a charge variable so
the charge is going to be all the chars
or all the characters
um in this text piece so we're going to
make a
uh sorted
set
of
text here and we're going to just
uh print out chars
so look at that we have a giant array of
all these characters so now we can what
we can do is we can use something called
A tokenizer and A tokenizer consists of
an encoder and a decoder what an encoder
does is it's actually going to convert
each character or sorry each element of
this array to an integer so maybe
this would be a zero this would be a one
right so a new a new line or an enter
would be a zero a space would be a one
exclamation mark would be a two
Etc right all the way to uh the length
of them and then what we could do is we
could even uh we could even print the
length of these characters
so we can see how many there actually
are so there's 81 characters in the
entire in in the entire Wizard of Oz
book so I've written some code here that
is going to do that job for us the job
of tokenizers so what we do is we just
use a little generator some generator
for Loops here generative formula for
Loops rather and we make a little
mapping from string standards and
integers to Strings given the vocabulary
so we just enumerate through each of
these uh we have one assigned wait first
element assigned to a one second
assigned to a two is that true right
that's basically all we're doing here
and we have an encoder and a decoder so
let's say we wanted to
convert the string hello to integers so
we go encode
and we could do
hello just like that and then we could
uh go ahead and print this out
perfect let's go ahead and run that boom
so now we have a conversion from
characters to integers and then if we
wanted to
maybe convert this back so decode it we
can store this in a little maybe decoded
uh hello equals that and then we could
go uh
or encoded rather
[Music]
encoded hello and then we could go uh
decoded
uh hello is equal to we go decode and we
can use the encoded hello
so we're going to go ahead and encode
this into integers and then we're going
to decode the integers back to a
character format
so let's go ahead and print that out
we're going to go ahead and print the
decoded hello
perfect so now we get that so I'm going
to fill you in on a little background
information about these tokenizers so
right now we're using the Character
level tokenizer which takes basically
each character and converts it to an
integer equivalent so we have a very
small vocabulary
and a very large amount of tokens to
convert so if we have 40 000 individual
characters it means we have a small
vocabulary to work with but a lot of
characters to encode and decode right if
we have
if we work with maybe a word level
tokenizer that means we have a ton like
every single word in the English
language I mean if you're working with
multiple languages this could be like
you know a lot very large amount of
uh tokens so you're gonna have like
maybe millions or billions or
trillions if you're if you're doing
something weird but
in that case you're going to have a way
smaller uh set to work with so you're
gonna have very large vocabulary but a
very small amount to encode and decode
so if you have a sub word tokenizer that
means you're going to be somewhere in
between a character level and a Word
level tokenizer if that makes sense
so in the context of language models
it's really important that we're
efficient with our data and just having
a giant string might not work the best
and we're going to be using a machine
learning framework called Pi torch or
torch so I've imported this right here
and pretty much what it's going to do is
it's going to handle a lot of the math a
lot of the calculus for us as well a lot
of a lot of the linear algebra which
involves a type of data structure called
tensors
so tensors are pretty much matrices if
you're not familiar with those that's
fine we'll go over them more in the in
the course but pretty much what we're
going to do is we're going to just put
everything inside of a tensor so that
it's easier for pi torch to work with so
I'm going to go ahead and delete these
here
and
all we can do is just
make our data element we could this is
going to be the entire text Data of the
entire Wizard of Oz
so we could go ahead and make this
uh data equals
and we're going to go torch.tensor
and then we're going to go encode we're
going to put the text inside of that so
we're going to go ahead and encode this
text right here
and we're going to make sure that we
have the right data type which is a
torch.long uh dated data type equals
torch
dot long
so this basically means we're just going
to have this as a super long sequence of
integers
and
yeah let's go see what we can do with
this torch.tensor element right here
so I've just written a little print
statement where we can just print out
the first 100 characters or 100 integers
of this data so it's it's pretty much
the same thing in terms of working with
arrays it's just a different type of
data structure
in the contents in the context of Pi
torch sort of easier to work with in
that way pytor is just primarily
revolved around tensors and modifying
them reshaping changing dimensionality
multiplying doing Dot products which I
mean that sounds like a lot but we're
going to go over some of this stuff
later in the course just about how to do
all this math we're going to actually go
over examples on you know how to how to
multiply this matrix by this Matrix even
if they're not the same shape and even
dot prodding dot producting that kind of
stuff so next one I'm going to talk
about is something called validation and
training splits so why don't we just you
know use the entire text document and
only train on that the entire text
purpose why don't we train on that well
the reason we actually split into
training and validation sets I'm going
to show you right here so we have this
giant Text corpus it's a super long text
file think of it as a you know an essay
but a lot of pages so this is our entire
Corpus and we make our training set you
know 80 of it so maybe this much and
then the other validation is this 20
right here okay
so if we were to just train on the
entire thing
after a certain number of iterations it
would just memorize the entire text
piece and it would be able to you know
simply write it just write it out it
would have it in the entire thing
memorized and it wouldn't really get
anything useful out of that it would
only know this document
but what the purpose of language
modeling is is to generate text that's
like the training data and this is
exactly why we put it into splits so if
we if we uh run our training split right
here it's only going to know 80 percent
of that entire Corpus
and it's only going to generate on that
80 instead of the entire thing and then
we have our other 20 which only knows
twenty percent of the entire Corpus so
the reason why we do this is to make
sure that the generations are unique and
not an exact copy of the actual document
we're trying to generate text that's
like the document like for example in on
drug or pothy's lecture he trains on
Shakespearean text an entire piece of
Shakespeare and the point is to generate
a Shakespearean like text but not
exactly what it looked like not that
exact you know forty thousand lines or
like a few thousand lines but that
entire Corpus right we're trying to
generate text that's like it so that's
the entire reason or at least that's
most of the reason why we use uh train
and valve splits so you might be
wondering you know like why is this even
called the bigram language model I'm
actually going to show you how that
works right now so we go back to our
whiteboard here I've drawn a little
sketch so if we have this piece of
content the word hello let's just say it
we don't have to encode it as any
integers right now we're just working
with characters
um pretty much we have two right so by
means two the buy prefix means two so
we're gonna we're gonna have a bigram so
given maybe I mean there's nothing
before an H in this content so
we just assume that's the start of
content and then that's going to point
to an H so H is the most likely to come
after uh to start and then maybe given
an H we're going to have an e then give
it an e we're going to have an l
think of an L we're going to have
another L and then L leads to O right so
maybe there's going to be
um
some probabilities associated with these
so that's pretty much how it's how it's
going to predict right now it's only
going to consider the previous character
to predict the next so we have given
this one we predict the next so there's
two which is why it's called biogram
language model
so ignore my terrible writing here but
we're actually going to go into how we
can train the bigram language model to
do what we want how we can actually
implement this into a neural network an
artificial neural network uh and train
it so we're going to get into something
called block size which is pretty much
just taking a random snippet out of this
entire Text corpus here just a small
snippet and
we're going to make some predictions and
we're going to make some targets out of
that so our block size is just a bunch
of encoded characters or integers that
we have predictions and targets so let's
say we take a small little size of maybe
a block size of five okay so we have
this tiny little tensor of five integers
and these are our predictions so given
some context right here we're going to
be predicting these
and
then we have our targets which would be
offset by one so notice how here we have
a five and then here the 5 is outside
and then this 35 is outside here and now
it's inside so all we're doing is just
taking that block uh from the
predictions in order to get the targets
we just offset that by one
so we're going to be accessing the same
indices so at index 0 it's going to be
five index 0 is going to be 67 right so
67 is following five in the background
language model so that's pretty much all
we do we just look at
how much of a difference is that a
Target away from or how much far is the
prediction away from the Target and then
we can optimize for reducing that error
so the most basic python implementation
of this in the Character level
tokenizers or the Character level
um
tokens rather would be just simply this
right here so we would we would take
um we would take a little snippet random
uh it would be
pretty much just from the start or some
some whatever just some snippet all the
way from the start of the snippet up to
block size so five
ignore my terrible writing again
um and then this one would just be
it would just be one
to block size or five
plus one so we'll be up to six right
and that's that's pretty much all we do
this is exactly what it's going to look
like in the code so I've written some
code here that does exactly what we just
talked about in Python so I've defined
this block size equal to eight just so
you can kind of see what this looks like
on a larger scale
a little bit larger and just what we
wrote uh right there in the Jupiter
notebook this uh
uh position zero up to block up to block
size and then offset by one so we make
it uh position one up to block size plus
one a little offset there uh we pretty
much just wrote that in here x as our
Productions as and Y as our targets and
then just a little for Loop to show
um
what the prediction and what the targets
are so this is what this looks like in
Python great we can do predictions but
this isn't really scalable yet this is
sequential right sequential it is
another way of describing what the CPU
does CPU can do a lot of complex
operations very quickly but it only
happens sequentially it's this one and
then this task and this task and this
task right but with gpus you can do a
little bit more simpler tasks but very
very quickly or in parallel so we can do
a bunch of very uh small or not
computationally
complex computation
in a bunch of different little
processors that aren't as good but
there's tons of them so pretty much what
we can do is we can take each of these
little blocks and then we can stack them
and push these to the GPU to scale our
training a lot so
I'm going to illustrate that for you
right now so let's just say we have a
block okay block looks like this and we
have some
we have some integers in between here
okay
so this
is a block okay
now if we want to make multiple of these
we're just going to stack them so we're
going to make another one
another one
another one so let's say we have four
batches okay or sorry four blocks
so we have four different blocks that
are just stacked on top of each other
and we can represent this as a new hyper
parameter called batch size this is
going to tell us how many of these
sequences can we actually process in
parallel so the block size is the length
of each sequence and the batch sizes how
many of these are we actually doing at
the same time so this is a really good
way to scale language models and without
these you can't really expect any fast
training or good performance at all so
we just went over how we can actually
get batches or rather how we can use
batches to accelerate the training
process and we can it just takes one
line to do this actually so all we have
to do is call this little function here
saying F Cuda dot torch.cuda is
available we'll just check if the GPU is
available based on your Cuda
installation and if it's available like
it says it's available we'll set the
device to Cuda else CPU so we're going
to go and print out the device here so
that's going to run and we get Cuda so
that means
we can use the GPU for a lot of our
processing here and while we're here I'm
actually going to move up this hyper
parameter block size up to the top
block size and then we're going to use
batch size which is how many blocks
we're doing in parallel and we're just
going to make this four for now so these
are our two hyper parameters that are
very very important for training and
you'll see that why these become much
more important later when we scale up
the data and use more complex mechanisms
to train and learn the patterns of the
language based on the text that we give
it so if it doesn't work right away if
the new Jupiter notebook doesn't work
right away I'd recommend just hitting
Ctrl C to cancel this hit it a few times
might not work the first
it'll shut down and you just go up
jupyter notebook again and then enter
it's done you should be able to just
restart that and
it will work hopefully
there we go
so I can go ahead and restarting clear
outputs
and we can run that see we get boo so
awesome
now let's try
to do some actual cool pie torch stuff
so we're gonna go ahead and import uh
torch here
and then
let's go ahead and try this uh Rand end
feature so we're going to run into
I will do equals torch.randint
[Music]
and then let's say we go minus a hundred
to a hundred and then in Brackets we go
uh six just like that so if we want to
print this out here
uh or we can just go around that like
that I could run this block first
good
boom so we get a tensor type and all
these numbers are we have we have six of
them so one two three four five six and
they're between negative 100 and 100. so
we're gonna have to keep this in mind
right here when we're getting our random
batches from this giant Text corpus
so let's try out a new one let's just
try uh we can make we can make tensors
we've done this before so we could do
tensor uh equals torch dots tensor
you go
um 0.1
.2
uh here I'll just copy and paste one
right here
so we do this boom
we could just do tensor and we'll get
exactly this
so we get a
three by two Matrix
now we're going to try a different one
called zeros so zeros is just
torch.zeros
and then inside of here we could just do
the dimensions or the shape of this so
uh two by three and then we can just do
zeros
and then go ahead and run that so we get
a two by three of zeros and these are
all floating Point numbers by the way
um maybe we could try ones now I know
ones is pretty fun one so we go torch
of course not ones it's pretty much the
same as zeros uh we could just do like
maybe three by four
and then
print that ones out so we have a three
by four of ones
sweet
so what if we do
input equals
torch.empty
uh we can make this two by three
so
these are interesting these are these
are pretty much uh
a bunch of very either very large or
very small numbers
um
I haven't particularly found a use case
for this yet but just another feature
that Pi torch has
we have a range
equals torch dot arrange
I like to do like five for example let
me just do
so now we have a tensor
um
just sorted uh zero or rather starting
at zero up to four so five just
just like that
[Music]
um
line space
[Music]
equals
torch dot line
line space spelling is weird two three
ten and then steps for example equals
five
this all makes sense in a second here we
go run
and we get a line space so steps equals
five so we have five different ones boom
boom boom boom boom and we go all the
way from three to ten so pretty much
getting all of the constant increments
from three all the way up to ten over
five steps so
uh you're doing you're basically adding
the same amount every time so three plus
one point seven five is four point seven
five and then plus another uh one one
ten five is six point five and then
eight point two five and then ten right
so just over five steps uh we want to
find what that constant increment is so
that's a pretty cool one
um and then we have
we'll do log space which is interesting
log space equals torch.logspace
and then we'll go
uh start
uh
start equals
negative 10.
and
equals 10 these are these are both start
and end so you can either put these here
you can either put the start with them
start equals or you don't have to that's
honestly up to you and then
we can put our steps again so steps
equals maybe five
let's go ahead and run that or oops into
I'm gonna put log space there
so we get that so we start at
um
one to the negative 10 and then we just
do this little increments here so it
goes 10 negative five zero plus five ten
for sure five steps so that's pretty
cool
um what else do we have here so we have
I
orange dot I I just have all these on my
second screen here so a bunch of
examples just written out and we're just
kind of visualizing uh what these can do
and maybe you might even have your own
creative little Sparks of
um about that you're gonna maybe find
something else that you can use these
for for your own personal projects or
whatever you want to do so first kind of
experiment experimenting with these uh
what we can do with the basics of Pi
torch and some of the very basic
functions
so uh first I we go uh
print this I out here so we get pretty
much just a diagonal line
and
it's it's in five so you get a five by
five Matrix and
yeah pretty much just uh reduced wrote
each long form I don't know how to
pronounce it but uh that's pretty much
what it looks like so pretty cool stuff
um let's see what else we have
we have empty like
we have empty like uh torch.emptylank
and then we'll just say
maybe make a equal to
we'll make it a torch.empty
and then we can go uh
two by three and then uh data type
torch dots into 64. so 64-bit integers
all right and then let's see what
happens here empty
[Music]
boom
so
that's pretty cool what else do we have
yes we can do timing as well so
I'm just going to erase all of these uh
you can I mean
if you can scroll back in the video just
look and maybe experiment with these a
little bit try a little bit more than
just you know what I've done with them
maybe modify them a little bit
um
but yeah I'm actually going to delete
all these here so here's dude
and then we can go ahead and do the
device
equals uh Cuda and we're going to go
ahead and switch this over to the Cuda
GPT environment okuda if
torch dot Cuda
uh
underscore is
dot Cuda is
available
[Music]
all right and then else
let's see if you print out our device
here
and run this
Cuda Suite
so we're gonna try to do stuff with uh
the GPU now compared to the CPU and
really see how much of a difference uh
Cuda or the GPU is going to make in
comparison to the CPU when we change uh
the shape and dimensionality and we're
just doing different
experiments with a bunch of different
tensors so in order to actually measure
the difference between the GPU and the
CPU I just imported a library called
time so this comes with the operating
system or sorry with with python you
don't have to actually install this
manually so basically what we do is we
do whenever we call time dot time and
then wrap up
parentheses it will just take the
current time snippet right now so start
time will be like right now and then end
time maybe three seconds later will be
you know right now plus three seconds so
if we subtract n time I start time we'll
get a three second difference and that
would be the total all apps time and
then this little number here this four
will be just how many decimal places we
have so I can go ahead and run this here
time is not defined let's run that first
boom
I'm just going to take you know almost
no time at all so we can actually
increase this if we want to 10.
and then run that again again it's you
know we're making out pretty much a one
by one Matrix so just a it's just a zero
so uh we're not really going to get
anything significant from that
um but
anyways for
[Music]
we're actually testing the difference
between the GPU and the CPU what we're
going to worry about is that iterative
process the process of forward pass and
back propagation through the network
that's primarily what we're trying to
optimize for actually pushing all these
parameters and all these
um model weights
to the GPU isn't really going to be the
problem it'll take maybe a few seconds
at most like maybe 30 seconds to do that
and that's not going to be any time at
all in the entire training process so
what we want to do is just see you know
which is better numpy on the CPU
or torch using Cuda on the GPU so I have
some code for that right here
so we're going to initialize a bunch of
matrices here
so or sorry tensors and we have just
basically random ones so we have a ten
thousand by ten thousand uh all random
all random floating Point numbers and
then we're going to push these to the
GPU now we have two of these and then
same thing for numpy
so in order to actually multiply
matrices with pi torch we need to use
this at symbol here
so we multiply these and we get this new
uh we get this new uh random tensor and
then we stop it and then we do the same
thing over here except we use
numpy.multiply so if I go ahead and run
these
[Music]
it's going to take a few seconds to
initialize these and or not even a few
seconds and then we have
see look at that so
for the GPU it took a little while to do
that and then for the CPU it didn't take
as long so this is because there's
shape of these matrices are not really
that big they're just two dimensional
right so it's the C this is something
that the CPU can do very quickly because
there's not that much to do but let's
say we want to bump it up a notch so if
we go to 100
100 100 and then maybe we'll throw in
another 100 there hopefully that works
and then we can do uh we'll just do the
same thing so we'll just paste this
so now if we try to run this again
you'll see that the GPU actually took
less than half the time that the CPU did
and this is because uh there's you know
a lot more going on here there's a lot
more simple uh multiplication to do so
the reason why this is so significant is
be because when we have you know
millions or billions of parameters in
our language model we're not going to be
doing uh very complex operations between
all these tensors they're going to be
very similar to what we saw in here the
dimensionality and shape is going to be
very similar to what we're seeing right
now you know maybe three or four
dimensions uh
and it's going to be very easy for our
GPU to do this they're not complex tasks
that we need the CPU to do they're not
very hard at all so when we uh
give this task to parallel processing
it's going to be a ton quicker so you're
going to see why this matters later in
the course you're going to see this with
some of the hyper parameters we're going
to use which I'm not going to get into
quite yet but uh over the next little
bit you're going to see why the GPU is
going to matter a lot for increasing the
efficiency of that iterative process so
this is great now you know a little bit
more about why we use the GPU instead of
the CPU for training efficiency so
there's actually another term that we
can use called a percentage percentage
time I don't know if that's exactly how
you're supposed to call it but that's
what it is and pretty much what it'll do
is time how long it takes to execute a
block so we can see here there's CPU
times zero nanoseconds the n is for Nano
a billionth of a second is a nanosecond
and then wall time so CPU time is how
long it takes to execute on the CPU the
time that it's doing operations for and
then the wall time would be how long it
actually takes like in real time how
long do you have to wait do you have to
wait until it's finished so the only
thing that the CPU cpu10 doesn't include
is waiting so in an entire process
there's going to be some operations and
there's going to be some waiting while
time is going to have the uh both of
those and CPU time is just the execution
so let's go ahead and continue with some
of the basic Pi torch functions so I've
written some stuff down here so we're
going to go over
torch.stack torch dot multinomial
torch.trail uh Trio I don't think that's
how you pronounce it but we'll get into
that more
transposing linear concatenating and the
softmax function
so let's first start off here with the
Torresdale millinomial
so this is essentially a probability
distribution based on the index that you
give it so we have probabilities here we
say 0.1 and 0.9 these numbers have to
add up to one to make a hundred percent
100 is one one whole so I have 10 and 90
percent
this is at index zero so there's a ten
percent chance that we're going to get a
zero and a ninety percent chance that
we're going to get a one so if I go
ahead and run these up here
give this a second to do its thing so we
you can see that uh in the end we have
our num sample set to 10 so it's going
to give us 10 of these one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten and
all of them are ones if we run it again
it will make it slightly different
results see now we have some zeros in
there but the zeros a very low
probability of happening as a matter of
fact exactly a ten percent probability
of happening so we're going to use this
later in uh predicting what word is
going to come next
let's move on to torch got torch.cat or
short for tors dot concatenate so this
will essentially concatenate two tensors
into one so I initialize this tensor
here torch.tensor uh one two three four
it's one dimensional
and
we have another tensor here that just
contains five so if we concatenate one
two three four and five then we get
uh one two three four five let me just
combine them together and
uh this is what will come out in the end
so we run that one two three five
perfect
so this is gonna we're gonna actually
use this when we're generating when
we're generating text given a context so
it's going to start uh it's going to
start from zero we're going to use our
probability distribution to pick the
first one and then
uh based on the first one we're going to
uh you know we're gonna we're gonna
predict the next character and then once
we have predicted that we're going to
concatenate uh the new one with the ones
that we've already predicted so we have
this maybe like 100 characters over here
and then the next character that we're
predicting is over here we just
concatenate these and by the end we will
have all of the uh integers that we've
predicted
so next up we have torch.trill and what
this stands for what the trill stands
for is a triangle lower so it's going to
be in a sort of a triangle formation
like this diagonal it's going to be
going from uh top left to bottom right
and so you're going to see a little bit
more why later in this course but this
is important because when you're
actually trying to predict uh integers
or next tokens in the sequence
you have you only know what's in the
current history we're trying to predict
the future so giving the answers in the
future
isn't what we want to do at all so maybe
we've just predicted one and the rest of
them we haven't predicted yet so we set
all these to zero and then we predicted
another one and these are still zero so
these are talking to each other in
history and as and as our predictions
add up
we have more and more history to look
back to endless future right
um basically the premise of this is just
making sure we can't communicate with
the answer we can't predict while
knowing what the answer is just like
when you write an exam
can't use the answer they don't give you
the answer sheet so you have to know
based on your history of knowledge
which answers to predict and that's all
that's going on here
and we have I mean you could probably
guess this triangle upper so we have all
the upper ones these are you know lower
on the lower side and then these are on
the upper side so same concept there
and then we have
a masked fill so this one's going to be
very important later because in order to
actually get to this point all we do is
we just exponentiate every element in
here so if you exponentiate zero
if you exponentiate zero it'll become
one
if you exponentiate negative Infinity
it'll become zero
all that's going on here is we're doing
at approximately
2.71 and this is a constant that we use
in the dot exp function and then we're
putting this to whatever
power is in that current slot so we have
a zero here so
2.71 to the zeroth is equal to one
2.71 to the one
is equal to 2.71
and then
2.71 to the negative uh
Infinity is
of course zero so that's pretty much how
we get from this to this
and we're just we're simply just masking
these over so
that's great and I sort of showcase what
the EXP does we're just using this one
right here we're using this this output
and we're just plugging it into here so
it'll go from negative Infinity to zero
and then zero to one so so that's how we
get from here to here
now we have uh
transposing so transposing is when we
sort of Flip or swap the dimensions of a
tensor so in this case I initialize a
torch.0 tensor with Dimensions two by
three by four
and we can use the transpose function to
essentially flip any Dimensions that we
want
so what we're doing is we're looking at
the zeroth as it sounds weird does not
say First Dimension but we're pretty
much swapping the zero width position
with the second so zero one two we're
swapping this one with this one so the
end result like you would probably guess
the shape of this is going to be 432
instead of two three four so you can
kind of just take a look at this and see
you know which ones are being flipped
and those are the dimensions and that's
the output so hopefully that makes sense
next up we have torch.stack and this is
where we're actually going to go uh
we're gonna we're gonna do more of this
we're actually going to use torch.sack
stack very shortly here when we're
getting our batches so remember before
when I was talking about batch size
and how we take a bunch of these blocks
together and we just stack them a giant
uh a giant length of integers or tokens
and all we're doing is we're just
stacking them together in blocks or to
make a batch so that's pretty much what
we're going to end up doing and that's
what torch.stack does so we can take
something that's maybe one dimensional
and then we can stack it to make it
two-dimensional we can take something
that's two-dimensional and stack it a
bunch of times to make it
three-dimensional
or we can
say three-dimensional for example we
have a bunch of cubes and we stack those
on top of each other now it's four
dimensional so hopefully that makes
sense all we're doing is we're just
passing in each tensor that we're going
to stack in order
so this is our little output here and
that's pretty much all it is the next
function that's going to be really
important
Forum model and we're going to be using
this the entire time from start to
finish it's really important it's called
the nn.linear function so it is a pretty
much a function of the NN dot module and
this is really important because you're
going to see later on nmdot module
is it can
think that has
learnable parameters so when we do a
transformation to something when we
apply a weight in a bias in this case
it'll be false but
pretty much when we apply a weight or a
bias under an N dot module it will learn
those and it'll become better and better
train based on
how accurate those are and how close
certain parameters bring it to the
desired output so pretty much anything
with nn.linear is going to be
very important and it's going to be
learnable so we can see over here this
is the torch ONN little site here on the
docs so we have containers a bunch of
different layers like activations layers
uh
uh pretty much just layers that's all it
is and
so these are these are important we're
gonna
we're basically going to learn from
these and you're going to see why now
we're going to use something called keys
and values
Keys values and queries later on you'll
see why those are important but uh
if that doesn't make sense yet help me
let me illustrate that for you right now
so
I drew this out here so if we look back
at our examples
we have a uh we make we initialize a
tensor
um
it's 10 10 and 10. what we're going to
do is we're going to do a linear
transformation this linear stands for
linear transformation so
pretty much we're just going to apply a
weight and a bias through each of these
layers here so we have an input and we
have an output X is our input Y is our
output and this is of size three and
this is of size three so pretty much we
just need to make sure that these are
lining up and for more context
the NN dot sequential is
sort of built off an indot linear so if
we go ahead and search that up right now
this will make sense in a second here
there's also some good prerequisite
knowledge in general for machine
learning
so let's see and then dot sequential
uh it doesn't show it here but pretty
much
um
if you have let's say uh two you have
two input neurons
and maybe you have one output now okay
you have a bunch of hidden layers in
between here
let's say we have
one two three four and then one two
three
so pretty much you need to make sure
that the inputs aligns with this hidden
layer this hidden layer aligns with this
one and this one aligns with this one so
you're going to have a transformation of
two to four so two four and then this
one's going to be
four to three four to three and then
you're gonna have a final one this is
two to four right here four to three
here and then this final one it's going
to be three to one so you pretty much
just need to make sure that these are
lining up so we can see that we have two
four and then this four is carried on
from this output here and
pretty much this will just make sure
that shapes are consistent and of course
if they aren't consistent if the shapes
don't work out the math simply won't
work so we need to make sure that our
shapes are consistent if that didn't
make sense I know I'm not like super
great at explaining uh architectural
Nets but if you're really interested
I could use chat CPT of course that's a
really good Learning Resource chat GPT
going on GitHub discussions maybe or
just looking at documentation and if
you're not good at reading documentation
then you could take
maybe some some little keywords from
here like
a sequential container well what is a
sequential container you can ask chat
CPT those types of questions and just
sort of virtual engineer the
documentation and figure things out step
by step it's really hard to know what
you're doing if you don't know all of
the math and all of the functions that
are going on you don't need to memorize
them
while you're working with them it's
important to understand what they're
really doing behind the scenes
especially if you want to make
an efficient and properly working neural
net so
that's that and pretty much what's going
to happen here with these linears is
linear layers is we're just going to
Simply transform from one to the other
input to Output no hidden layers and
we're just going to be able to learn
best parameters for doing that and
you're going to see why that's useful
later
um
now we have the softmax function so that
sounds scary and the softmax function
isn't actually what it sounds like at
all
um let me illustrate that for you right
now so let's go ahead and change the
color here
so let's say we have a array we have a
one two and three let's move we'll make
them floating Point numbers 2.0 3.0 Etc
right floating points whatever so pretty
much if we put if we put this into the
softmax function
what's going to happen is we're going to
exponentiate each of these and we're
going to divide them by the sum of all
of these exponentiated so pretty much
what's going to happen let's say we
exponentiate one okay
so what that's going to do is it's going
to do
this is what it's going to look like in
code it's going to go one dot e x p
XP I think I talked about this up here
this is exponentiating when we have 2.71
to the power of whatever number we're
exponentiating
so if we have this one we're going to
exponentiate that and that's going to
give us
that's going to give us 2.71
we have this 2 here and that's going to
give us whatever
whatever 2 is exponentiated 2.71
.
power of two okay so we're going to hit
7.34
I'm gonna get seven point three four or
my writing it's terrible
0.71
3 cubed so 19.9
so pretty much what's going to happen is
we we can rearrange this in a new array
7.34 and 19.9
so if we add all these up together
we had all these up together we're going
to 2.71 plus this one so let's do this
math real quick I'm just going to walk
you through this to help you understand
what the softmax function is doing 7.24
Plus 19.9
that's going to give us a total of 29.95
great
29 point
five
so all we do is we just divide each of
these elements by the total so 2.71
divided by this is going to give us
maybe X okay
and we do 7.34 divided by this it's
going to give us Y and then we have 19.9
divided by this it's going to give us
Z
so pretty much
you're going to exponent exponentiate
all of these you're going to add them
together to create a total and you're
going to divide each of those
exponentiated Elements by the
exponentiated total so
after that this x right here is just
we're just going to wrap these again and
all this softmax function is doing is
it's converting this one two three to
XYZ that's all it's doing
um and yeah it's it's not really it's
not really crazy there's a weird formula
for it
soft Max
it's not the max function
so if you go on Wikipedia
I'm gonna crap yourself because there's
a lot of terms in here and a lot of math
that's you know above the high school
level but uh yeah like this formula here
I believe this is what it is or standard
unit there you go so pretty much this is
what it does and there's your easy
explanation of what it does so
uh you're gonna see why this is useful
later but it's just important to know
what's going on so that
background knowledge becomes important
so if we go over a little example of
that of the softmax function in code it
looks like this right here so we import
torsa and not functional as F actually
for functional
and we pretty much just do F Dot softmax
and then plug in a tensor and what we
want the dimension to be the output
Dimension so
if we plug this into here and we print
it out let me go and print it out
it's going to take a second
unfortunately it's not defined so let's
run this from the top here
[Music]
and let's try that again boom there we
go so if you took all those values let's
actually do this again from scratch so
we do 2.71
divided by
29.95
again 0.09
3.09 good
add and then if we do
7.34
divided by 29.95 we get 0.245
0.245 logs kind of close
um it's really close actually and then
66.52 so if we go uh what was that last
one there 19.9
for you 19.9 divided by 25.95
66.4 so 66.5 it's pretty close uh again
we're rounding so it's not perfectly
it's not perfectly accurate but as you
can see they're very close and for you
know only having two decimal places uh
we did pretty good so that's just sort
of illustrating with the sawback softmax
function does and what it looks like in
code we have this
this sort of shape here zero Dimensions
means
we just take
you know it's just a kind of a straight
line it's just just like that
um
so now we're going to go over embeddings
and I'm not actually I don't have any
code for this yet we're going to figure
this out step by step with Chachi BT
because I want to show you guys uh sort
of the skills and what it takes to
reverse engineer an idea or function or
just understand if something works in
general and machine learning so if we
pop into chat CBT here
we say
what is
NN Dot
and dots
m
and non-bedding class in the pie charts
Library okay actual language processing
Max maps each discrete input to a dense
Vector representation okay
how does this work let's see so we have
some vocab so that's probably our
vocabulary size so I think we we talked
about that earlier vocabulary size how
many characters how many unique
characters are actually in our data set
that's the vocabulary size and then some
embedding Dimension here which is a
hyper parameter
so
let's see
this doesn't quite make sense to me yet
so maybe I want to learn what does this
actually look like
and you explain this to a
I don't know maybe an eighth grader
and provide a visualization
certainly okay
[Music]
little secret codes that represent the
meaning of the words okay that helps
so if we have cat Okay so cat
's a word so
maybe we want to know what it would look
like on a character level
what about on me
character level is
third level
so it's probably going to look very
similar we have this little Vector here
storing some information about whatever
this is
so a it means this here okay so a is 0.2
and
this is really useful so we've pretty
much just learned what embedding vectors
does and and if you haven't kept up with
this pretty much what they'll do is
they'll store some Vector of information
about this character
and we don't even know what each of
these elements mean we don't know what
they mean this could be maybe positivity
or should be the start of a word or it
could be any piece of information maybe
something we can't even comprehend yet
but the point is if we actually give
them vectors and and
we feed these into a network and
learn because as we saw before
NN dot embedding right here is a
part of the n and module so these are
learnable parameters which is great
so it's actually going to learn the
importance of each letter and it's going
to be able to produce some amazing
results so in short the embedding
vectors are essentially a vector or a
numerical representation of the
sentiment of a letter
in in our case it's character level not
sub word not word it's character level
so it's going to represent some meaning
about those so that's what embedding
vectors are let's go figure out how they
work in code we have this little
character level embedding vector
and it contains a list there's five
elements in here one two three four five
and
it's by the vocab size so we have all of
our vocabulary by the length of each
embedding Vector so this actually makes
sense because our vocab size by the
embedding Dimension which is how much
information is actually being stored in
each of these characters so this now is
very easy to understand I'm just going
to copy this code from here
I'm going to paste it down here and
let's just get rid of the torch
torch.net because we already initialized
that above
so if if we just run this actually let's
turn that down to maybe a thousand
characters let's try that out
and then it's not defined well we did
not initialize it
works
[Music]
so let's go back down here and look at
that so uh this dot shape is going to
essentially show the shape of it
This Much by uh by this much so it's
four by a hundred
and
yeah so we can we can work with these
and we can store stuff about characters
in them and
uh you're going to see this in the next
lecture how we actually use embedding
vectors so no need to worry if a lot of
this doesn't make sense yet that's fine
you're going to learn a little bit more
about how we use these over the course
you're going to get more confident with
using them even in your own projects so
don't don't stress about it too much
right now embeddings are pretty tricky
at first to learn so don't worry about
that too much but there are a few more
things I want to go over uh just to get
us prepared for some of the linear
algebra and matrix multiplication in
particular that we're going to be doing
uh in neural networks so if we have I
remember before we pulled out this a
little sketch of uh this is actually
called a multi-layer perceptron but
people like to call it a neural network
because it's easier to say
but that's the architecture of this a
multi-layer perceptron
um but pretty much what's happening is
we have a little input here and we have
a white Matrix so weight Matrix is looks
like this
looks like this we have some we have
some values in between X1
y1
and maybe Zed is that one so a bunch of
uh weights and and maybe biases too that
we add to it so
the tricky part is how do we actually
multiply our input by this weight Matrix
we're just doing one Matrix times
another well that's called matrix
multiplication and I'm going to show you
how to do that right now
so first off we have to learn something
called dot products so
dot products are actually pretty easy
and you might have actually done them
before
so let's say we go ahead and take we go
ahead and take this array here we go
um one two three that's going to be what
a is and then we have
um four five six
so if we want to find the dot product
between these two uh all we have to do
is simply take the index of both of
these uh the first ones and the second
ones the third ones multiply them
together and then add so we're going to
go ahead and do uh one multiply four one
times four and then add it to
times five
and then add it to three times six
so one times four is four two times
three times six is eighteen so I'm gonna
go ahead and add these up we get 14 plus
18 I believe is 32 so
the dot product of this
is going to be 32 and that's pretty much
how simple dot products are it's just
taking
each index of both these arrays
multiplying together and then adding all
of these
um
that's a DOT product so we actually need
dot products for matrix multiplication
so let's go ahead and jump into that
right now so I'm just going to create
two matrices that are going to be pretty
easy to work with
so let's say we have a
an F1 Matrix over here it's going to be
we have one two three four
five and six
this is going to be equal to a and then
B
is going to be another Matrix so we're
going to have
seven
eight nine
10 11 12. ignore my terrible writing
um
pretty much what we do is to multiply
these together first we need to make
sure that they they can multiply
together so we need to take a look at
the amount of rows and columns that
these have so this one right here is
three rows one two three three rows and
two columns so this is going to be a
three by two Matrix and this one has two
rows and three columns so it's a two by
three Matrix
so all we have to make sure that if
we're multiplying
a
dot product with b and this is the pi
torch Syntax for multiplying matrices
if we're multiplying a by B then
we have to make sure uh the following is
true so if we use uh three by two
and then uh dot product with two times
three we have to make sure that these
two inner values are the same so 2 is
equal to two so we cross these out and
then the ones that we have left over are
three by three so the resulting Matrix
would be a three by three
however if you had like a three by four
times a 5 by
uh five by one that doesn't work because
these values aren't the same so these
two matrices couldn't multiply
and sometimes you actually have to flip
these to make them work so maybe we we
change this value here to a three
which changes value to a three
in this order they do not multiply but
if we switch them around
we have a
uh we have a three by five
with a
three by or sorry five by three sorry
five by three with a three by four so
these two numbers are the same that
works and the resulting Matrix is a five
by four so that's how you make sure that
two matrices are compatible
so now to actually multiply these
together what we're going to do I'm
going to make a new line here so we're
going to I'm going to rewrite these
uh now we don't have to rewrite them
what's that out here
so pretty much what we have to do is we
have to take
these two
and Dot product with these two and since
we're done that
we do the same with these and these
these and these
so we start with the first the first row
in the a matrix
and we iterate through all the columns
in the B Matrix
and then after we're done that we just
go to the next row in the a matrix and
then Etc right so let's go ahead and do
this right now that probably sounds
confusing to start but let me just
illustrate this how this sort of works
right here so we have our one times uh
are one times seven
plus two times ten so
1 times 7
plus 2 times 10.
and this is equal to 27. so
that's the first dot product of 1 and 2
and 7 and 10. so what this is actually
going to look like in our new Matrix go
ahead and write this out here so this is
our new Matrix here
this 27 is going to go right here
let's continue
so next up we're going to do one and two
and then 8 and 11.
I'm just gonna go one uh
one times eight
Plus
at 2
or sorry
to end
11.
so 1 times 8 is 8 and then 2 times 11 is
22. so our result here is 30. and 30
is just going to go
right here so 27 30 and you can see how
this is going to work right so we in our
in our first uh in our first row of a
we're going to get the first row of this
resulting Matrix
so let's go ahead and do the rest here
so we have uh one and two and then 9 and
12.
times nine
uh 2 times 12.
times 9 is 9 2 times 12 is 24 so if we
do uh
that's like 33 I believe so
33 and we can go ahead and write that
here
so now let's move on to the next so we
have a three and four
three
and four dot product was seven and ten
so
3 will multiply 7.
and then we're going to go ahead and add
that
to
4 times 10.
3 times 7
3 times 7 is 21 and then 4 times 10 is
40. so we're gonna get 47 so I'll put
there so we can go ahead and write
47 right there
next one is going to be uh
three and four dot product with 8 and
11.
so
States
Plus
four times eleven
X so we get 3 times 8 is 24 and then
[Music]
plus 44 so
24 plus 44 that's 68.
so we get 68
and we can go ahead and write that here
so next up we have 3 and 4 and 9 and 12.
so 3 times 9 is 27
and then 4 times 12 so let's just let's
just do that I'm not doing that in my
head
uh 27 plus was 4 times 12 so that's 48
27 plus 48 gives us 75.
75 here
then we can go ahead and slide down to
this row since we're done since we're
done that and then we go five uh five
and six dot product was seven and ten
foreign
so our result from this uh 5 times 7 is
35 and then 6 times 10 is 60 so we're
going to get 95.
we can go and write our 95 here
and then
uh five and six dot product with 8 and
11.
5 times 8 is 40 and then 6 times 11 is
66 so we get 104.
and then the last one so five and six
dot product with 9 and 12.
so 5 5 times 9 is 45 and then 6 times 12
is
uh what's 6 times 12 is 72 I think
so
6 times 12 72 yeah so 45 Plus 72.
117.
and that is how you do a three by two
Matrix and a two by three Matrix
multiplying them together
so uh the result would be uh
C
equals that so
as you can see it takes a lot of steps
that took actually quite a bit of time
compared to a lot of the other stuff
I've covered in this video so far so you
can see how it's really important to get
computers to do this for us and
especially to scale this on a GPU so I'm
going to keep emphasizing that point
more and more it's how the GPU is very
important for scaling your training but
pretty much that's how you dot products
and matrix multiplication so I actually
realized I messed up a little bit on the
math there so this 104 uh that's
actually 106. so I messed up there if
you caught that
uh good job but pretty much this is what
this looks like in three lines of code
so all of this up here
that we just covered all this is in
three lines so we initialize an a tensor
and a b tensor
uh each one of these is a row each one
of these is a row and
it'll pretty much multiply these
together so this at symbol this is a
shorthand how you multiply two matrices
in pi torch together
another way to do this is to use the
torch Dot Matrix multiply function or
maximal for short and then you can do a
and b so these will print literally the
same thing
look at that
so
I'm not too sure on the differences
between them I use uh a at B for short
but if you really want to know just you
know take a look at the documentation or
astronaut CPT one of the two and should
be able to get an answer from that
but
I'm going to move on to something that
we want to watch out for especially when
we're doing our
matrix multiplication in our networks so
where's our Network here if I go up
imagine we have uh we have some Matrix
some Matrix a and
every element in this Matrix is a
floating Point number so
if it's like a one it would be like 1.0
or something or just like a one dot
that's what it would look like as a
floating Point number but if it were an
integer say B is full of ones with
integers it would just be a one there
wouldn't be any decimal zero zero Etc
right it would just be one
so in pi torch you cannot actually
multiply integers and floating Point
numbers because they're not the same
data type so
I showcase this right here we have an
N64 so uh type of it is an integer and a
float32 uh 64 and 32 don't mean anything
all we have to know is an integer and
floating Point number so I've
initialized a course.rand end I covered
above
and set above here
[Music]
and
thank you
uh maybe not
anyways
this pretty much does a torch.randint is
going uh the first parameter here is
anything
it's pretty much your range so
I could do like zero to five or I could
just do like one so it'll do zero up to
one and then uh your shape of the Matrix
that it generates so
I said it's a random int so that means
it's going to generate a tensor with the
data type integer 64.
so we have a three by two and then I
initialize uh another random uh
p uh key detail here we don't have the
uh int suffix so this just generates
floating Point numbers
and if we actually return the types of
each of these so if I print
um
int 64 dot d type
and then
float32.d type
save that I'm just going to cover this
up for now
uh
we get a N64 and floor 32. so if we just
try to multiply these together
[Music]
expected scalar type long above found
float so long is pretty much when you
have a sequence of integers
and Float is of course you have the
decimal place so you can actually
multiply this together so
pretty much what you can do is cast the
float method on this if you just dot
float and then parentheses and then run
this
it'll actually work so you can cast
integers to floats and I think there's a
way you can cast floats to integers but
it has some rounding in there so
probably not the best for uh input and
weights matrix multiplication but
pretty much if you're doing any weight
or matrix multiplication it's going to
be using floating Point numbers because
the weights will get extremely precise
so you want to make sure that they have
sort of room to float around
so that's pretty much how you avoid that
error let's move on so congratulations
you've probably made it farther than
quite a few people already so
congratulations on that that was one of
the most comprehensive parts of this
entire course understanding uh the math
that's going on behind the scenes for
some people it's very hard to grasp if
you're not very fluent with math
um
but yeah let's continue the biogram
language models and let's pump up some
code here so
to recap we're using Cuda to accelerate
the training process we have two hyper
parameters block size for the length of
integers and batch for how many of those
are running in parallel
two hyper parameters we open our text uh
we make some we make a vocabulary out of
it we initialize our encoder and decoder
we get our data encoding all this text
and then
we get our train and bow splits
and then this next function here get
batch
so before I jump into this
I'm going to run this here so this is
pretty much just taking the
uh
first little I don't know we have eight
characters so it's taking the first
eight characters and then
index one all the way to index nine so
it's offsetting by one and we can pretty
much use this to
show what the
current input is and then what the
target would be so if we have 80 Target
is 1 80 and 80 and one target is one
idiot one and one target is 28 Etc right
so this is the premise of the diagram
language model given this character
we're going to predict the next it
doesn't know anything else in the entire
history it just knows what's before it
or just knows what the current character
is and based on that we're going to
predict the next one
so
we have the sketch get batch function
here and this part right here is the
most important piece of code this is
gonna this is gonna work a little bit
more later with our train and bow splits
making sure that's
you know I'll try to explain this in a
different way with our training bow
splits so imagine you're you take a
course
as you take a math course okay and
ninety percent of all your work is done
just learning how the course Works
learning all about the math
so that's like 90 of theta you get from
it and then maybe another 10 percent
another 10 at the end is that final exam
which might have some questions you've
never seen before so the point is in
that first 90 you're tested on uh based
on what you know and then this other uh
10 is what you don't know and this
pretty much means you can't memorize
everything and then just start
generating based on your memory you
generate something that's alike or
something that's close based on what you
already know and the patterns you
captured uh in that ninety percent of
the course
so you can write your final exam
successfully
so that's pretty much what's going on
here the training is the course
learning everything about it and then
validation is validating the final exam
so
pretty much what we're doing here is we
initialize IX and that'll take a random
random integer between uh
pretty much between zero and then length
of the length of the entire text minus
block size so if you uh if you get the
index that's at like the Theta minus
block size it'll you'll still get the
characters up to the length of data so
that's kind of how that works and if we
print this out here it'll just give us
this right here so we get some random
integers these are some random uh
indices in the entire text that we can
start generating from so
print this out and then torch.stack we
covered this before pretty much what
this does it's just going to stack them
in batches this is the entire point of
batches so
that's what we do there we get X and
then Y is just the same thing but offset
by one like this
so that's what happens there and let's
get into
actually I'm going to add something here
this is going to be very important we're
going to go
X
I'm going to go X and Y is equal to
model dots or we're going to go
x dot two
device
so notice how
uh no we didn't do it up here okay we'll
cover this later but
pretty much
you're gonna see what this does in a
second here
to device
we return these
and you can see that the device changed
so now we're actually on Cuda and this
is really good because
uh this these these two pieces of data
here the inputs and the targets are no
longer on the CPU they're no longer
going to be processed sequentially but
rather in our batches in parallel so
that's pretty much how you push any
piece of data or parameters to the gpus
just dot two and then the device which
you initialized appear so now we can go
ahead and actually initialize our neural
net so what I'm going to do is I'm going
to go back up here and we're going to
import some more stuff
so I'm going to import at torch.nn
as NM and you're going to see why a lot
of this is important in a second I'm
going to explain this here I just want
to get some code out first
[Music]
and down here we can initialize this so
it's a class we're going to make it
bigram
language model
subclass event.module
and the reason why we do in and Dot
module here
is because
it's going to take in
it's going to take an inundo module I
don't know how to explain this like
amazingly but pretty much when we use
the NN dot module functions in pi torch
and it's inside of a an indot module
subclass
uh
they're all learn they're all learnable
parameters so I'm going to go ahead and
look at the documentation here so you
can sort of understand this better
if we go to NN okay
so
pretty much all these uh convolutional
layers our current layers Transformer
linear like we looked at linear layers
before so we have an end.linear so if we
use nn.linear
inside of this that means that the
nn.linear parameters are learnable so
that white Matrix will be changed
through gradient descent
and actually I think I should probably
cover gradient descent right now so in
case some of you don't know what it is
it's going to be really hard to
understand exactly how we make the
network better
so I'm going to go ahead and set up a
little graph for that right now so I'm
going to be using a little tool called
Desmos Desmos is actually great it acts
as a graphing calculator so you can plug
in formulas and move things around just
sort of visualize how math functions
work so I've written some functions out
here that'll basically calculate the
derivative of a sine wave
so if I move a around you'll see that
changes so
before I get in to what's really going
on here I need to First tell you what
the loss actually
if you're not familiar so the loss let's
say we have 80 characters in our
vocabulary and we have just started our
model no training at all completely
random weights theoretically there's
going to be a 1 in 80 chance that we
actually predict next token successfully
so
how we can measure the loss of this is
by taking the negative log likelihood
so the likelihood is one out of 80. we
take the log of that and then negative
so if we plug this in here we'll get
4.38 so that's a terrible loss obviously
that's one out of 80. so it's like
you know not even two percent chance
so that's not great
so pretty much the point is to minimize
the loss increase the prediction
accuracy or minimize the loss and that's
how we train our Network so how does
this actually work how does this
actually work out in code you ask so
pretty much let's say we have a loss
here okay start off with a loss of two
just arbitrary loss whatever and
what we're trying to do is decrease it
so over time it's going to become
smaller and smaller
if we move in this direction
so how do we know if we're moving in the
right direction well we take the
derivative of what it's uh what the
current point is at right now and then
we try moving in a different direction
so if we move it this way sure it'll go
down that's great we can hit the local
bottom over there or we can move to this
side and then we can see that the slope
is increasing in a negative Direction so
we're gonna we're gonna keep adjusting
the parameters in favor of this
direction so that's pretty much what
gradient descent is where uh descending
with the gradient so pretty
self-explanatory that's what the loss
function does
and gradient descent is an Optimizer so
it's an Optimizer for the network
optimizes our parameters our weight
matrices Etc
so
these are some common optimizers that
are used and this is just by going to
torch.optim
short for Optimizer and these are just a
list of a bunch of optimizers that Pi
torch provides so
what we're going to be using is
something called atom W and what Atom W
is is it pretty much uh
I'm just going to read off my little
script here because I can't memorize
every Optimizer that exists
um
so
atom without Adam just Adam not MW atom
is a popular optimization algorithm that
combines ideas of momentum
and it uses a moving average of both the
gradient and its squared value to adapt
the learning rate of each parameter and
the learning rate
is something that we should also go over
so
let's say I figure out I need to move in
this direction I move I take a step like
that
okay that's a very big step that I say
okay we need to keep moving in that
direction so what happens is I go I go
like this and then I end up there and
it's like whoa we're going up now what
happened
so that's because you have a very high
learning rate if you have a lower
learning rate what will happen is you'll
start here you'll take little one pixel
steps or very very small steps Click
Boom okay that's good that's better it's
even better keep going in this direction
this is great and you keep going down
you're like okay this is good we're
descending and it's oh it's starting to
flatten out
so we know that we're hitting a local
bottom here
and then we stop because it starts
ascending again
so that means this is our best set of
parameters
because of uh
because of what that loss is or what the
derivative is of that particular point
so
pretty much
this is what the learning rate is so you
want to have a small learning rate
so that you don't take two large steps
so the parameters don't change
dramatically and end up messing you up
so you want to make them small enough so
you can still have efficient training
like you don't want to be moving in like
you know Millions like a millionth of
you know
uh you know a millionth of one or
something like that'd be ridiculous
you'd have to do so many iterations to
even get this far so maybe you'd make it
you know
like decently high but not too high that
it'll go like that right so that's what
the learning right is just how how fast
it learns pretty much
and uh
yeah so Adam W is a modification of the
atom optimizer
and it adds weight decay so pretty much
there's just there's just some features
that you add on to gradient descent and
then atom W is the same thing except as
weight Decay and what this pretty much
means is it generalizes the parameters
more so instead of having very high
level performance for very low level it
takes a little generalize in between so
uh the weight significance will actually
shrink as it's uh as it flattens out
so this will pretty much make sure that
certain parameters in your network
certain parameters in your weight
matrices aren't affecting
the output of this model drastically
that could be in a positive or negative
Direction you can have insanely high
performance from some lucky uh
parameters in your weight matrices
so pretty much the point is to minimize
those to Decay those values that's what
weight Decay is to prevent it from
having that insane uh or super low level
performance that's what weight Decay is
so that's a little background on
gradient descent and optimizers
Let's uh let's go ahead and finish
typing this out so
next up
we actually
uh we need to initialize some things
so
we have
our emit
off of course since it's a class vocab
size I want to make sure that's correct
vocabulary size
I might actually shrink this just a
vocab size because it sounds it's way
easier to type out
uh
boom
[Music]
and vocab side is good so
we're gonna we're gonna pump out some
more code here and this is just assuming
that you have some sort of a background
in Python if not it's all good
just understanding the premise of what's
going on here
so
we're going to make something called an
embedding table
and I'm going to explain this to you in
a second here why why the embedding
table is really important
notice that we use uh the nn
we use the N module in this so that
means this is going to be a learnable
parameter of the init.embedding
so we're going to make this vocab size
by low cap size
so you have all so let's say all 80
characters here and you have all 80
characters here
I'm going to actually show you what this
looks like in a second here and why this
is really important but first off we're
going to finish we're actually going to
finish typing out this diagram language
model
so we're going to Define our forward
pass here
so
the reason why we type this forward pass
out instead of just using what it offers
by default is to
let's say we have a specific use case
for a model and we're not just you know
using some tensors and we're not we're
not doing a simple task this is is
really good practice because
we want to actually know what's going on
behind the scenes in our model we want
to know exactly what's going on we want
to know what Transformations you're
doing how we're storing it and just a
lot of the behind the scenes information
that's going to help us debug so I
actually asked this to chat GPT says why
is it important to write a forward pass
function in pi Torch from scratch so
like I said understanding the process
what are all the Transformations that
are actually going on all the
architecture that's going on in our
forward pass getting an input running it
through a network and getting an output
um
our flexibility
debugging like I said debugging is gonna
debugging is gonna it's gonna bite you
in the ass
if you don't uh sort of follow these
best practices because
if you're using weird data and the
default isn't really used to
dealing with it you're going to get bugs
from that so you want to make sure that
when you're actually going through your
network you're handling that data
correctly and each transformation it
actually lines up so you can also print
out at each step what's going on so you
can see like oh this is not quite
working out here maybe we need to you
know use a different function maybe this
isn't the best one for the task right so
it'll help you out with that especially
and of course customization if you're
building custom models
custom layers right
and
optimization of course so
that's pretty much why we write out the
forward pass from scratch it's also just
best practice so it's never really a
a good idea to not write this
but let's continue so self and then
we'll do
index and targets
so
we're going to jump into a new term here
called logic but before we do that I'm
kind of all over the place here before
we do Logics I'm going to explain to you
uh this embedding table here
paste that in
return plugins
you're gonna see why we return marches
in a second here so
this an end on embedding here is pretty
much just a lookup table so what we're
going to have I'm actually going to pull
up my notebook here
so we have a
a giant sort of grid of what the
predictions are going to look like
is going to look can I drag it in here
no
so go ahead and download this full
screen boom
this is in my notion here but pretty
much this is what it looks like and I
took this picture from Andre carpathy's
lecture but
what this is is it has start tokens and
end tokens to start is at the start of
the block and and tokens are at the end
of the block
and
it's pretty much just predicting
it's showing sort of a probability
distribution of what character comes
next given one uh given one character so
if we have
say I don't know an a
6640 times
uh out of this entire distribution here
so if we just add up all these if we
normalize them
and we get a little probability of this
happening I don't know if we if we add
up all these together I don't know what
that is something some crazy number like
maybe 20 20 000 or something something
crazy pretty much that percentage is
the percentage of the the end token
coming after the character a
and then same thing here like if we do
uh R that's an RL or an RI I don't know
I'm blind that's an RI
but pretty much we normalize these which
means
normalizing means you take uh you take
how significant is that to that entire
row so this one's pretty significant uh
in proportion to the others so this
one's going to be a fairly high
probability of coming next a lot of the
times you're going to have an I coming
after an r and that's pretty much what
that is that's the embedding table so
that's why we make it vocab size by
vocab size
so that's a little background on what
we're doing here so
let's continue with the term logits so
what exactly are the logits you're
probably asking that so
let's actually go back to the little
notebook I had over here
so
remember our softmax function right our
stop Max right here so we exponentiated
each of these values and then we
normalize them normalized we took uh its
contribution to the sum of everything
that's what normalizing is so you can
think of logits as just
a bunch of floating Point numbers that
are normalized right so
you have a you have a total right here
I'll write this out so let's say we have
uh
that's a terrible line let's draw a new
one
good okay
so
let's say we have
uh
let's say we have two
four
and six
and we want to normalize these so
take two out of the totals What's the
total we have six plus four is ten plus
two is twelve so 2 divided by 12.
we take the percentage of that 202 out
of 12 is 0.16
something okay
so
0.16 we'll just one place uh 0.167 and
then 4 out of 12 would be double that so
4 out of 12 would be 33 33 percent
and then 6 out of 12 well that's 50. so
0.5
so that's what this looks like
normalized and this is pretty much what
the logits are except it's it's more of
a probability distribution so
let's say we have you know a bunch of a
bunch of bigrams here like I don't know
a followed by B and then
uh a followed by C and then a followed
by D
we know that from this distribution a
followed by D is most likely to come
next so this is what the logits are
they're pretty much a probability
distribution of what we want to predict
so given that
let's hop back into here we're going to
mess around with these a little bit
so
we have this embedding table and I
already showed you what that looked like
like this right here this is our
embedding table
so
let's use something called we're going
to use a function called Dot View so
this is going to help us sort of reshape
what our logits look like and I'm going
to go over an example of what this looks
like in a second here I'm just going to
pump out some code
so we have our batch by our time so the
time is you can think of time as
um
that sequence of integers that's the
time Dimension right you start from here
maybe through the generating process we
don't know what's here next
we don't know what's on the we don't
know what the next token is so that's
why we say it's time because there's
some we don't know yet and there's some
that we already do know
that's why we call it the time dimension
and then channels would just be how many
different channels are What's the
vocabulary size channels is the
vocabulary size
so we can make this the lotus.shape
this is what loja is going to return
here is B by T by C that's the shape of
it and then
our targets
do
actually we won't do that yet we'll do
logics
equals logits Dot View and then we'll
this is very important
B by T so because we're particularly
paying attention to the channels the
vocabulary
uh the batch in time
they I mean they're not as important
here so we can sort of blend these
together and as long as the logits and
the targets have the same batch in time
which should be all right so we're going
to do B uh B times T by C
and then
we can go ahead and initialize our
targets it's going to be
targets
Dot View
and it's going to be
just a b by T
and then we can make our loss remember
the loss function right so we do that
functional of cross entropy which is
just a way of measuring the loss and we
basically take there's two parameters
here
so we have the
logits
and the targets so I'm going to go over
exactly what's going on here in a second
but first you might be asking what does
this view mean what exactly does this do
so I'm going to show you that right now
I've written some code here that
initializes a random tensor of shape two
by three by five
and so what I do is I pretty much unpack
those uh I unpack those dimensions
by using a DOT shape so shape takes the
you know it takes the
two by three by five we get x equals two
y equals three and Z equals five so
then we can do Dot View and that'll
pretty much uh
make that tensor again with those
dimensions
so then we can just print that out
afterwards we go
we can print out
I don't know print x y z
I have two three five
print a DOT shape
actually I'll print out a DOT shape
right here first so you can see
that this actually does light up
a DOT shape
and then down here as well
same exact thing it's also viewed us
basically allows us to unpack with the
dot shape and then you can use view to
put them back together into a tensor so
you might be asking why in this notebook
did we did we have to reshape these why
do we do that well the answer sort of
falls into
what the shape needs to be here with
cross entropy what does it expect what
does pytorch expect the actual shape to
be so uh I looked at the documentation
here and it pretty much says that we
want uh
either one dimension which is channels
or two which is n which I believe n is
also the batch so you have n n different
blocks or batches
and then
you have some other dimensions here so
pretty much what is what's what it's
expecting is a
a b by C by T instead of a b by T by C
which is
precisely what we get out of here is the
logits.shape is B by T by C and we want
it in a b by C by T
so pretty much what we're doing is we're
just putting this into what we're just
making this one parameter by multiplying
those that's what's going on here and
then that means the second one is going
to be C so you get like a like a b times
T equals n and then C just the way that
it expects it right just like that
so
that's pretty much what we're doing
there
a lot of the times you might get errors
from passing it into a functional
function in in pi torch so it's
important to pay attention to how
pytorch expects the shapes to be because
you're going to get errors from that and
I mean it's it's not very hard to
reshape them you just use the dot view
and Dot shape and you unpack them
reshape them together just it's it's
overall pretty simple for uh
beginner to intermediate level projects
so shouldn't really be a trouble there
but just watch out for that because it
will come back and get you if you're not
aware at some point so I've added a new
function here it's called generate and
this is pretty much going to generate
tokens for us so we pass an index which
is uh the current index or the context
and then we have Max new tokens and this
is passed in through here so we have our
context
we make it a single zero just uh just
the next line character
and then we generate based on that and
then our Max new tokens second parameter
we just make it 500
so cool what do we do inside of here we
have a little Loop that pretty much
it uh it generates uh
based on the length of or the range of
the max new tokens so we're going to
generate
Max new tokens tokens if that makes
sense
pretty much what we do is we call
forward Pass based on the current state
of the model the model parameters and I
want to be explicit here and say
self.forward rather than just self-index
it will call self.4 when we do this but
let's just be explicit and say self dot
forward here
so we get the larger than the loss from
this
we focus on the last time step that's
the only one we care about is diagram
language model we only care about this
single previous character only one
doesn't have context before
and then we apply the softmax to get a
probability distribution and we already
went over the softmax function before
the reason why we use uh negative one
here is because we're focusing on the
last Dimension and in case you aren't
familiar with negative indexing which is
what this is here and same with here is
imagine you have a little number line
okay so it starts at index 0 1 2 3 4 5
Etc so if you if you go before zero it's
just going to Loop to the uh very end of
that array
so when we call negative one it's going
to do the last element negative two
second last element negative three third
last element Etc so that's pretty much
all this is here and you can do this for
anything negative indexing is
quite common so
that's what we do here we apply soft Max
to the last Dimension and then
we sample from the distribution so we
already went over torch.melynomial
we get one sample
and this is pretty much the next index
or the next encoded character that we
then use torch.cat short for concatenate
it concatenates the previous context or
the previous tokens with the newly
generated one and then we just combine
them together so they're one thing
and
we do this on a v by T plus one
and if that doesn't make sense let me
help you out here so
we have this time Dimension let's say we
have you know maybe just one element
here so we have something in the zeroth
position and then whenever we generate a
token we're going to take the
information from the zeroth position and
then we're going to add one to it so it
becomes a b by T since there was only
one element the length of that was one
it is now two
then we have this two we make it three
and then we have this three and we make
it four
so that's pretty much what this doing
let's just keep just keep concatenating
um
more tokens onto it and then we you know
after this Loop we just return the index
so this is all the generated tokens for
Max new tokens
and
that's pretty much what that does
um
model.2 device here this is just going
to push our parameters to the GPU it's a
more efficient training
I'm not sure if this makes a huge
difference right now because we're only
doing background language modeling
but
uh yeah it's handy to have this year
and then I mean this is this is pretty
self-explanatory here we generate based
on a context this is the context which
is just a single zero or an X line
character
passenger Max new tokens uh and then we
pretty much just decode this so
that's how that works uh let's move on
to the optimizer and the training Loop
the actual training process so I
actually skipped something and probably
left you a little bit confused but
you might be asking how the heck do we
actually access the second out of out of
three dimensions from this logits here
because the logits only returns two
Dimensions right you have a b by T
or you have a b times T by C so how
exactly does this work well
I'm going to call this forward pass
while we're passing in is the index here
so that means targets defaults to none
so because targets is none
the loss is none and this code does not
execute and it just uses this logits
here which is three-dimensional
so that's how that works and honestly if
you if you're feeding in uh your inputs
and your targets of the model then
you're obviously going to have your
Targets in there and
that will make sure targets is not none
so then you'll actually be executing
this code and you'll have a
two-dimensional Logics rather than a
three-dimensional logos so that's just a
little clarification there if that was
confusing to anybody another quick thing
I want to cover before we jump into this
training Loop is
this little torch.long data type so
torched out long is the equivalent of
int64 or integer 64 which occupies 64
bits or 8 bytes
so
you can have different data types you
can have a float 16 you can have a float
32 float 64 I believe you can have an
INT 64
in 32 difference between float and int
is float has decimals it's a floating
Point number and then integer is just
just a single integer doesn't it's not
really anything more than that it can
just be bigger based on the amount of
bits that it occupies so that's just a
overview on torch.long it's the exact
same thing as in in 64. so
that's that now we have this we have
this training Loop here so
we Define our Optimizer and
I already mounted over optimizers
previously uh atom W which is Adam White
Decay so we have white decay in here
and then all of our model parameters
and then our learning rate so I actually
wrote to learning right up here so I
would add this and then just rerun this
part of the code here if you're typing
along
um so I have this learning rate as well
as Max Ayers which is how many
iterations we're going to have in this
training Loop
and the learning rate is special because
sometimes you're learning what will be
too high
sometimes it'll be too low so a lot of
the times you'll have to experiment with
your learning rate and see which one
provides the the best both performance
and quality over time so with some
learning rights you'll get really quick
advancements and then it'll like
overshoot that little dip so
you want to make sure that doesn't
happen but you also want to make sure
the training process goes quickly
you don't want to be waiting like you
know an entire month for a biogram
language model to train by having you
know
by having a number like that
so
that's a little overview on uh like
basically we're just putting this this
learning right in here that's where it
belongs so now we have this training
Loop here which is going to iterate over
the Max iterations and we just give each
iteration the term editor
and I don't think we use this yet but we
will later for just reporting on the
loss over time
but what we do is we get
we get a batch with the transplant
specifically we're just again we're just
we're just training this is the training
Loop we don't care about validation so
we're going to call train on this we're
going to get some X inputs and some y
targets
so
we go ahead and do a model.forward here
we got our logits and our loss
and then
we're going to do our optimizer.zerograd
and I'll explain this in a second here
it's a little bit confusing but
again we have our we have our lost dot
backward and this in case this doesn't
sound familiar in case you are not
familiar with training Loops I know I
can go by this a little bit quickly but
this is the the standard training Loop
architecture for basic models and this
is what it'll usually look like so
you'll you know you'll you'll get your
data you get your inputs your outputs
whatever
you'll do a forward pass you'll Define
something about the optimizer here in
our case Zero grad
and then
you'll have a lost dot backward which is
about backward pass and the optimizer
dot step which lets gradient descent
work its magic
so
back to
optimizer.zerograd so by default Pi
torch will accumulate the gradients over
time via adding them
and
what we do by by putting zero grad is we
make sure that they do not add over time
so the previous gradients do not affect
the current one
and the reason we don't want this is
because previous gradients are from
previous data and the data is you know
kind of weird sometimes sometimes it's
biased and we don't want that
determining you know how much like what
our error is right so we only want to
decide we only want to optimize based on
the current gradient of our current data
and this little parameter in here we go
set to none this pretty much means we're
going to set uh
we're going to set the gradients instead
of zero instead of zero gradient we're
going to set it to none and the reason
why we set it to none is because none
occupies a lot less space
it just yeah it just occupies a lot less
space when you have a zero that's in
that's probably an in 64 or something
that's going to take up space and
because
uh you know we might have a lot of these
accumulating that takes up space over
time so
we want to make sure that the set to
them is true at least for this case
sometimes you might not want to
that's pretty much what that does it
will if you do have a zero grad on
commonly the only reason you'll need it
is for training large recurrent neural
Nets which need to understand uh
previous context because they're
recurrent I'm not going to dive into
rnns right now but those are a big use
case for not having zero grad gradient
accumulation we'll simply take an
average of of the accumulation steps and
just averages the gradients together so
you get a more effective maybe block
size right you get more context that way
and you can have the same batch size so
just little neat tricks like that we'll
talk about gradient accumulation more
later in the course
but pretty much what's going on here we
Define an Optimizer atom w
ow we iterate over Max headers we get a
batch training split we do a forward
pass zero grad backward pass and then we
get a step in the right direction so
we're gradient descent works is Magic
and then at the end we could just print
out the loss here so I've run this a few
times and over time I've gotten the loss
of 2.55 which is which is okay and if we
generate based on that loss
we get
you know
still pretty garbage tokens but then
again yeah this is a background language
model so
I might need to retrain this here it's
not trained yet so I'm actually gonna do
let's run this run this run this boom
and then what I'll do oh looks like
we're printing a lot of stuff here so
that's coming from our get batch so I'll
just
comment that I already just delete it
overall
cool
and now if we run this again
give it a second
[Music]
perfect
so I don't know why it's still doing
that
uh if we run it again let's see
where are we printing stuff
[Music]
batch
no
ah yes we have to run this again after
changing it silly me
and
of course 10 000 steps is a lot so it
takes a little while takes a few seconds
it's actually quite quick so after uh
the first one we get a loss of 3.15 we
could generate from that
and we get something that is less
garbage you know it has some next line
characters it understands a little bit
more to you know space things out and
whatnot so
uh that's like slightly less garbage
than before but
uh yeah this this is pretty good
so I lied there aren't actually any
lectures previously where I talked about
optimizers so might as well talk about
it now
so we have a bunch of common ones and
honestly you don't really need to know
anything more than the common ones
because
uh most of them are just built off of
these
so you have your mean squared error
common loss function using regression
regression problems where it's like you
know you have a bunch of data points
find the best fit line right that's a
common regression problem goal is to
predict a continuous output it measures
the average square difference be between
the predicted and actual values often
used to train neural networks for
aggression tests so cool
um that's the most basic one you can
look into that more if you'd like but
that's our most big basic Optimizer
gradient descent is a step up from that
used to minimize the loss function in a
model
measures how well the model
the gradient measures how well the model
is able to predict the target variable
based on the input features so we have
some input X we have some weights and
biases maybe WX plus b
and
all we're trying to do is make sure that
the inputs or or make sure that
we we make the inputs become the desired
outputs and based on how far it is away
from the desired outputs we can change
the parameters of the model so
we went overcrate indescent recently or
previously but that's that's pretty much
what's going on here
and momentum is just a little extension
of gradient descent
that adds the momentum term so it helps
smooth out the training
and allows it to continue moving in the
right direction even if the gradient
changes direction or varies magnitude
it's particularly useful for training
deep neural Nets so momentum is when you
have you know you consider some of the
other
gradients so you have something that's
like maybe passed on from here and then
it might include a little bit of the
current one so like 90 percent like a
good momentum coefficient would be like
90 previous gradients and then 10 of the
current one so it kind of like lags
behind and makes it converge sort of
smoothly that makes sense
RMS prop I've never used this but it's
it's an algorithm that uses the moving
average of the squared gradient to adapt
learning rates of each parameter helps
to avoid oscillations and the parameter
updates and can move and can improve
convergence in some cases so you can
look more into that if you'd like
Adam very popular
combines the ideas of momentum and RMS
prop
it uses a moving average both the
gradient and its squared value to adapt
the learning rate of each parameter it's
often used as the default Optimizer for
deep learning models and in our case uh
when we continue to build this out it's
going to be quite a deep net and atom W
is just a modification of the atom
Optimizer that adds white Decay to the
parameter updates so helps to regularize
and it can prove generalization
performance we'll be using this
Optimizer as it Best Suits the
properties of the model we'll train this
video
so of course I'm reading off the script
here there's no really other better way
to say how these optimizers work but
yeah if you want to look more into you
know Concepts like momentum or white
Decay or you know oscillations and just
some statistic stuff you can but
honestly the only thing that really
matters is just knowing which optimizers
are used for certain things so like what
is that what is the moment what is
momentum used for what is atom W great
for what is MSE good for right just
knowing what the difference is
similarities are as well as
when is the best case to use the
optimizer so
yeah you can find more information about
that at torch.optum so when we develop
language models something really
important in language modeling data
science machine learning at all is just
being able to report a loss or get an
idea of how well our model is performing
over you know the first thousand
iterations and then the first 2000
iterations then four thousand iterations
right so we want to get a general idea
of how our model is converging over time
but we don't want to just print every
single step of this that wouldn't make
sense
so we actually could do is print every
you know 200 iterations 500 we could
print every 10 000 iterations if you're
running a crazy big language model if
you wanted to and that's exactly what
we're going to implement right here so
actually this this doesn't require an
insane amount of python syntax this is
just uh I'm actually just going to add
it into our for Loop here
and what this is going to do is it's
going to do what I just said is print
every you know
every certain number of iterations so we
can add a new hyper parameter up here
called eval iters
and I'm gonna make this 250 just for
um just to make things sort of easy here
and
we're going to go ahead and add this in
here so I'm going to go
um
if it's her
and we're going to do the modulo
operator you can look more into this if
you want later
and we're going to do you Val editors
equals equals zero
this is going to do is it's going to
check if
uh
if the current iteration
divided by
or sorry if the
remainder of the current iteration
divided by our evaluators parameter
if if the remainder of that is zero then
we continue with it
so hopefully that made sense if you want
to you could just look at you could just
ask GPT you could just ask gpt4 or GPT
3.5 whatever you have uh just this
module operator and you should get a
good General understanding of what it
does
cool so all we can do now is we'll just
say we'll just have a filler statement
here we'll just do print
uh we've been F string
and then we'll go
losses
losses maybe not
or actually I'm going to change this
here we can go
step
enter
add a little coin in there
and then I I'll go
we'll go
Blitz
actually now we'll just go loss
and then
uh losses like that and then we'll have
some
so we'll put in here
something soon
I don't know
and all I've done is I've actually added
a little function here behind the scenes
you guys didn't see me do this yet but
pretty much
uh I'm not going to go through the
actual function itself but
what is important is that you know this
this decorator right here this probably
isn't very common to you so this is
torch.nograd and what this is going to
do is it's going to make sure that Pi
torch doesn't use gradients at all in
here that'll reduce computation it will
reduce memory usage it's just overall
better for performance and because we're
just reporting a loss we don't really
need to do any optimizing our gradient
computation here we're just getting
losses we're feeding some stuff into the
model we're getting a loss out of it and
we're going from there so that's pretty
much what's happening with this torch no
grad and
you know for for things like
I don't know if you have other classes
or other outside functions like I mean
get batch by default isn't using this
because it doesn't have the model thing
passed into it but estimate loss does
have model pass into it right here so we
just kind of want to make sure that it's
not using any gradients it reduce
computation that way so anyways uh if
you want you can just to take a quick
read over of this and it should overall
make sense uh terms like dot item dot
mean are pretty common uh a lot of the
other things here like model X and Y we
get our logic logic Center loss this
stuff should make sense should be pretty
straightforward
and only two other things I want to
touch on is model.eval and model.train
because you probably have not seen these
yet so
wild up train or model.train essentially
puts the model into training mode
the model learns from the data meaning
the lights and biases if we have both of
those sometimes you only have white
sometimes you you know sometimes you
have weights and biases whatever it is
those are updated during this phase
and then some layers of the model like
drop out and batch normalization which
you may not be familiar with yet
operate differently in training mode for
example Dropout is active and what
Dropout does
is this little hyper parameter that we
add up here it'll look like this drop
out maybe like 0.2 so pretty much what
Dropout does is it's going to drop out
random neurons in the network so that we
don't over fit
and
this is actually disabled in validation
mode or eval mode
so this will just help our model sort of
learn better when it has little like
pieces of noise and when things aren't
in quite the right place so that you
don't have you know certain neurons in
the network taking priority and just
making a lot of the heavy decisions we
don't want that so Dropout will just
sort of help our model train better by
taking 20 of the neurons out 0.2 at
random and that's all Dropout does so
I'm just going to delete that for now
uh
and then yeah Model A train well Dropout
is active during this phase uh during
training randomly turning off random
neurons in the network and this is to
prevent overfitting we went over
overfitting earlier I believe
and as for evaluation mode
evaluation mode is used when the models
being evaluated
or tested just like it sounds well it's
being trained what the other mode is
being validated or tested
and
layers like Dropout and batch
normalization behave differently this
mode Dropout is turned off in the
evaluation right because what we're
actually doing is we're using the entire
network we want everything to be working
sort of together
and we want to actually see how well
does it perform training mode is when
we're just you know sampling doing weird
things to try to challenge the network
so we're training it and then evaluating
or validation would be when we just get
the network in its optimal form and
we're trying to see how good of results
it produces so that's what a Val is and
the reason we switched into a Val here
is just because well we are testing the
model we want to see you know how well
it does with any given set of data from
a gitbatch
and we don't actually need a train here
there's no training if there was
training this would not be here because
we would not be using any gradients
we would be using gradients IF trainings
on anyways that's estimate loss for you
this function is you know just general
just general generally good to have in
data science your training validation
splits what not
and uh yeah good for reporting you know
how it is
and we can go ahead and add this down
here so there's something soon will go
losses is equal to
estimate
loss and then
uh
we can go ahead and put a
yeah we don't have to actually have to
put anything in here
cool so now let's go ahead and run this
uh let me run from the start here
um
perfect
[Music]
now we're running for 10 000 iterations
that's interesting
hahaha
okay
so
yes so what I'm going to do actually
here is you can see this last part is
weird
so I'm actually going to change this up
and I'm just going to switch it to
um we're gonna go train loss
and we're gonna go losses and we're
going to do the
train split
and then we're gonna go over here and
just do the
uh validation loss we do validation or
just Val for short
and
I'm gonna make it consistent here though
we have a column there we'll call in
here
and then you just go losses and
do Val cool
so I'm going to reduce these Max editors
up here only one thousand
run this
oh assuming didn't match
um
foreign yes so it actually happened here
was since we were using these little
ticks uh what was happening is these
were matching up with these and it was
telling us oh you can't do that you
can't start here and then end there and
have all this weird stuff like you can't
do that so pretty much we just need to
make sure that these are different so
I'm going to do a double quote instead
of single and then double quote to
finish it off and as you can see this
worked out here
so I'll just run that again so you guys
can see what this looks like and this is
ugly because we have you know a lot of
decimal places so we can actually do
here is we can add in a little formatter
or a little decimal place reducer if you
call it just for you know
uh so you can read it so it's not like
some weird decimal number and you're
like oh does this eight matter probably
not just like the first three digits
maybe so all we can do here is just add
in I believe this is how it goes
I don't think it's the other way
we'll find out
some stuff in Python is extremely
confusing to me
but uh
there we go so I got it right colon and
then period
and as you can see we have those digits
reduced so I can actually put this down
to 3F
wonderful
so we have our our train loss and our
validation loss
great job you made it this far this is
absolutely amazing this is insane it's
gotten this far in the video we've
covered all the basics uh everything you
need to know about biogram language
models optimizers training Loops
reporting losses I can't even name
everything we've done because it's so
much so congratulations that you made it
this far you should go take a quick
break give yourself a pat on the back
and uh get ready for the next part here
because it's going to be absolutely
insane we're gonna dig into literally
state of the art language models and
how we can build them from scratch or at
least how we can pre-train them and
some of these terms are going to seem a
little a little bit out there but I can
ensure you by the end of this next
section here
you're going to have a pretty good
understanding about the state of
language models right now
so uh yeah go take a quick break and
I'll see you back in a little bit so
there's something I'd like to clear up
and I actually sort of lied to you a
little bit uh a little while back in
this course about what normalizing is so
I recall we were talking about the
softmax function and normalizing vectors
so
the softmax is definitely a form of
normalization but there are many forms
there are not just a few or like there's
not just one or two normalizations there
are actually many of them and I have
them on my second monitor here but I
don't want to just you know dump that
library of information on your head
because that's not how you learn so
we're going to do is we're going to plug
this into gpt4 we're going to say
can you list all the forms
of
normalizing
in
machine learning
and
how are they different
from one another
gpd4 is a great tool if you don't
already use it I highly I highly suggest
you use it or even gbt 3.5 which is the
free version
but yeah it's a great tool for just
quickly learning anything and then you
know you could give it have it give you
example practice questions with answers
so you can learn topics in like
literally minutes that would take you
you know several lectures to learn in
you know a university course
but anyways there's a few here so min
max normalization yep
z-score decimal scaling mean
normalization unit vector or Layer Two
robust scaling power Transformations
okay
so yeah and then softmax would be
another one
what about
soft packs
it is in data type normalization but
it's not typically using for normalizing
input data
it's commonly used in the output layer
so softmax is a type of normalization
but it's not used for normalizing input
data
so I mean honestly we've proved that
here
by
by actually producing some probabilities
so this isn't something we used in our
you know forward pass this is something
we use in our generate function to get a
bunch of probabilities from our logits
so this is yeah interesting it's good to
just figure little things like these out
for you know just to just to be put you
on the edge a little bit more for the
future when it comes to engineering
these kind of things
all right great so the next thing I want
to touch on is activation functions and
activation functions are extremely
important in offering new ways of
changing our inputs that are not linear
so
for example if we were to have a bunch
of linear layers a bunch of uh let me
erase this
if they were to have a bunch of you know
and then dot linears in a row
what would actually happen is they would
all just you know they would all squeeze
together and it would essentially apply
one
transformation that sums up all of them
kind of they all sort of multiply
together and it gives us one
transformation that
is kind of just a waste of computation
because let's say you have a hundred of
these n and Dot linear layers
and
nothing else you're essentially going
from inputs to outputs but you're doing
a hundred times the computation for just
one multiplication that doesn't really
make sense
so what can we do to actually make these
deep neural networks important and what
can we offer that's more than just
linear transformations
well that's where activation functions
come in and I'm going to go over these
in a quick second here so let's go
navigate over to the pi torch docs so
three the three activation functions I'm
going to cover uh in this little part of
the video are the relu the sigmoid and
the tan age activation functions
so let's start off with the relu or
rectified linear unit
so we're going to use functional relu
and the reason why we're not just going
to use torch.n is because we're not
doing any forward passes here I'm just
going to add these into our
uh
I'm going to add these
let me clear this
let me clear this output that's fine
I'm actually going to add these into
here and there's no forward pass we're
just going to Simply run them through a
function and get an output just so we
can see what it looks like
so
I've actually added this up here from
torsionnn import functional as capital F
it's just kind of a common pie torch
practice capital s
and
uh let's go ahead and start off with the
relu here so we can go I don't know
x equals loot torch.tensor
and then we'll make it a
negative 0.05 for example
and then we'll go d-type equals torch
Dot float32
and we can go y equals F Dot relu
of X and then we'll go ahead and print y
has no attribute religion okay
let's try and then let's try and see if
that works
uh okay well that didn't work and that's
fine because we can simply take a look
at this and
uh it'll help us understand we don't
actually need to we don't need to write
this out in code as long as it sort of
makes sense we don't need to write this
in the forward pass really you're not
going to use it anywhere else
so uh yeah I'm not going to be too
discouraged that that does not work in
the functional library but
yeah so pretty much what this does is if
a number is below if a number is zero or
below zero
it will turn that number into zero and
then if it's above zero it'll stay the
same
so this graph sort of helps you
visualize that there's a little function
here
hope that might make sense to some
people I I don't really care about the
functions too much as long as I can sort
of visualize what the function means
what it does what are some applications
it can be used that usually covers
enough for like any function at all
so that's the regular function pretty
cool it simply offers a non-linearity to
our linear networks so if you have 100
layers deep and every I don't know
every second step you put a a relu that
Network's going to learn a lot more
things you can seem to learn a lot more
linearity non-linearity than if you were
to just have 100 layers multiplying all
into one transformation
so that's what that is that's the realu
now let's go over the sigmoid so here we
can actually use the functional uh the
functional Library
and all sigmoid does is we go one over
one plus exponentiated of negative X
so I'm going to add that here
uh
we could yeah why not do that negative
negative 0.054 float 32 sure we'll go f
Dot uh sigmoid
and then we'll just go X and then we'll
print y
cool so we had a tensor
0.4875 interesting
so this this little negative 0.05 here
is essentially
being plugged into this negative X so 1
over 1 plus 2.71 to the power of
negative negative 0.05
so it's essentially
if we do 2.71
2.71
to the power of
negative negative 0.5 we're just going
to get positive so
1.05 and then 1 plus that so that's 2.05
uh
let me just do one over that
2.05 so we get about 0 0.487 and what do
we get here
0.487 cool
so that's interesting and let's actually
look if is there is there a graph here
let's look at the uh
sigmoid activation function
Wikipedia don't get too scared by this
math here I don't like it either but I
like the graphs they're cool to look at
so this is pretty much what it's doing
here so
yeah it's just a little little curve
kind of looks like a
it's yeah it's kind of just like a wave
but it's
yeah it's it's cool looking that's what
the sigmoid function does it's used to
just you know generalize over this line
and yeah sigmoid function is pretty cool
so now let's move on to the tan h
the 10h function oh
Google Bing is or micro shopping is
giving me a nice description of that
cool
perfect e to the negative X I like that
So Tan H is a little bit different
there's a lot more exponentiating going
on here so you have uh well I'll just
say Expo or exp of x minus exp of
negative x divided by exp of X Plus e x
b of negative X it's there's a lot of
positives and negatives in here
positive positive negative negative
negative positive so
that's interesting let's go ahead and
put this into code here
so I'll go torch.examples or torch
examples this is our file here
and I'll just go
10h
cool
so
negative 0.05 cool what if we do a one
if we do a one here what will that
produce
oh 0.76
what if we do a 10.
1.0 interesting
so this is sort of similar to the
sigmoid except it's you know
let's actually ask you attach GPT what
the difference is
when would you use 10h over sigmoid
let's see here
sigmoid function and hyperbolic tangent
or tannage function our activations
functions use the neural networks they
have a similar s-shaped curve but have
different ranges so sigmoid output
values between a zero and a one well tan
H is between a negative one and a one
so if you're you know if you're rating
maybe the
maybe if you're getting getting a
probability distribution for example
you want it to be be between zero and
one meaning percentages or decimal
places so like 0.5 would be 50
0.87 would be 87 percent
and that's what the sigmoid function
does it's quite quite close to the
softmax function actually
except the soft Max just you know
it prioritizes the bigger values and
puts the smaller values to our priority
that's all the stop Mac says it's kind
of a sigmoid on steroids
and the 10h outputs between negative one
and one so
yeah you could maybe even start Theory
crafting and thinking of some ways you
could use
even the 10h function and sigmoid in
different use cases so that's kind of a
general overview on those so background
language models are finished all of this
we finished here is now done you're back
from your break if you took one if you
didn't that's fine too uh
but pretty much we're going to dig into
the Transformer architecture now and
we're actually going to build it from
scratch
so
there was recently a paper proposed
called the Transformer model so and this
uses a mechanism called self-attention
self-attention is used in these
multi-hat attention little bricks here
and there's a lot that happens so
there's something I want to clarify
before we jump right into this
architecture and just dump a bunch of
information on your little on your poor
little brain right now but
a lot of these networks at first can be
extremely confusing to beginners so I
want to make it clear it's perfectly
okay if you don't understand this at
first I'm going to try to explain this
in the best way possible believe me I've
seen tons of videos on people explaining
the Transformer architecture and all of
them have been to some degree a bit
confusing to me as well so I'm going to
try to clarify all those little
all those little pieces of you know
confusion like like what does that mean
you didn't cover that piece I don't know
what's going on here I'm going to cover
all those little bits and make sure that
nothing is Left Behind so you're going
to want to sit tight and pay attention
for this next part here
uh so yeah let's go ahead and dive into
just the general Transformer
architecture and why it's important so
in the Transformer Network you have you
know you have a lot of computation going
on you have some adding and normalizing
you have some multi-head attention you
have some feed forward networks there's
a lot going on here there's a lot of
computation a lot of multiplying a lot
of matrix multiplication there's a lot
going on so a question I actually had at
first was well if you're just you know
multiplying these inputs by a bunch of
different things along you should just
end up with some random value at the end
that maybe doesn't really mean that much
of the initial input
and that's actually correct for the
first few iterations the model has
absolutely no context as to what's going
on it it is clueless it is going in
random directions and it's just trying
to find the best way to converge
so this is what machine learning and
deep learning is actually all about is
having all these little parameters in
you know the adding and normalizing the
feed forward networks even multi-head
attention
we're trying to optimize the parameters
for producing an output that is
Meaningful that will actually help us
produce almost perfectly like English
text
and so this is the entire process of
pre-training you send a bunch of inputs
into a Transformer
and you get some output probabilities
that used to generate from
and
what attention does is it sets little
different scores to you know each little
each little token in a sentence for
tokens you have character sub word and
Word level Word level tokens
so you're pretty much just mapping bits
of attention to each of these as well as
you know what what is its position also
mean as well
so hit up two words that are right next
to each other
but then if you don't actually you know
positionally encode them it doesn't
really mean much because it's like oh
these could be like 4 000 characters
apart
so that's why you need both
uh to put attention scores on these
tokens and to positionally encode them
and that's what's Happening Here
so what we do is we get to our inputs
we got our inputs so I mean we went over
this with diagram language models
uh we feed our X and Y so X would be our
inputs y would be our targets or outputs
and
what we're going to do is give these
little embeddings so I believe we went
over embeddings a little while ago and
pretty much what those mean is it's
going to have a little it's gonna have a
little Row for each token on that table
and that's going to store you know some
some Vector as to what that token means
so let's say you had like
you know the character e for example
uh the sentiment or the the vector of
the of the character e is probably going
to be vastly different than the sediment
of Z right because e is a very common
vowel and Z is one of the most uncommon
if not the most uncommon letter in the
English language
so
these embeddings are learned we have
these both for our inputs and our
outputs we give them positional
encodings like I was talking about and
there's there's ways we can do that we
can we can actually use learnable
parameters to assign these encodings a
lot of these are learnable parameters by
the way and you'll see that as you you
know delve more and more into
Transformers
but uh
yeah so after we've given these inputs
embeddings and positional encodings and
same thing with outputs which are
essentially just shifted right you have
you know I up to block size for inputs
and then
uh I plus 1 up to block size plus one
right
or or whatever whatever little thing we
employed here in our background language
models I can't remember quite what it
was
or even if we did that at all
no
no I'm just speaking gibberish right now
but that's fine because it's going to
make sense in a little bit here
so
what I'm going to actually do is I'm not
going to read off of this right here
because this is really confusing so I'm
going to switch over to a little uh
like this little sketch that I drew out
and this is pretty much the entire
Transformer with a lot of other things
considered that this initial image does
not really put into perspective
so
let's go ahead and jump into sort of
what's going in going on in here from
the ground up so like I was talking
about before we have some inputs and we
have some outputs which are shifted
right
and we give each of them some embedding
vectors and positional encodings
so from here let's say we have n layers
this is going to make sense in a second
n layers is set to four so the amount of
layers we have is set to four so you can
see we have an encoder encoder like we
have four of these we have four decoders
so 4 is actually the amount of encoders
and decoders we have we always have the
same amount of each
so if we have you know 10 layers that
means we'd have 10 encoders and 10
decoders and pretty much what would
happen is after this after this input
embedding and positional embedding we
feed that into the first encoder layer
and then the next and then next and then
right as soon as we hit the last one we
feed these into each of these decoders
here each of these decoder layers
so only the last encoder will feed into
these decoders
and
pretty much
these decoders will all run they'll all
learn different things
and then they'll turn what they learned
they'll do they'll apply a linear
transformation at the end of it this is
not in the decoder function this is
actually after the last decoder it'll
apply a linear transformation
it's pretty much
sort of simplify or give a summary of
what it learned and then we apply a
softmax on that new you know tensor to
get some probabilities to sample from
like we talked about in the generate
function in our bigram
and then once we get these probabilities
we can then sample from them and
generate tokens and
that's that's kind of like the first
little step here that's what's that's
what's going on we have some encoders we
have some decoders we do a
transformation to summarize we have a
softmax to get probabilities and then we
generate based on those probabilities
cool
next up
in the encoder in each of these encoders
this is what it's going to look like so
we have multi-added tension which I'm
gonna which I'm going to dub into an
into is into a second here so after this
multi-head attention we have a residual
connection so in case you aren't
familiar with residual connections I
might have went over this before but
pretty much what they do is it's a
little connector
so
I don't know let's say you get some
inputs X you have some inputs X down
here and you you put them into some sort
of function here some sort of like feed
forward Network whatever it is a feed
forward network is essentially just a
linear a reloot and then a linear it's
all feed forward network is right here
linear really really linear
and
all you do is you wrap those uh you wrap
those inputs around so you don't
actually put them into that before
Network you actually wrap them around
and then you can add them to the output
so you had some X values here go through
the realu and then you had some wrap
around
and then right here you simply add them
together and you normalize them using
something called layer Norm which we're
going to cover in a little bit
and what the the reason why residual
connections are so useful in
Transformers is because when you have a
really deep neural network
a lot of the information is actually
forgotten in the first in the first
steps so if you have you know your first
your first view encoder layers in your
first few decoder layers A lot of the
information here is going to be
forgotten because it's not being carried
through the first steps of it aren't X
explicitly being carried through and you
know sort of skipped through the
functions
and yeah you can sort of see how this
they would just be forgotten so residual
connections are sort of just a cheat for
getting around that for not having the
April networks forget things from the
beginning and having them all sort of
work together to the same degree
so residual connections are great that
way and then you know at the end there
you would add them together and then
normalize and there's two different ways
that you can do this at a norm there's
add a norm and then Norman add so these
are two are these are two different
separate architectures that
you can do in Transformers and both of
these are sort of like meta
architectures but pretty much
pre-norm
is the normalized and add and then post
Norm is added normalize
so in this in this attention is all you
need paper proposed by a bunch of
research scientists was
initially you want to add these you want
to add these together and then normalize
them
so
that is what we call the Post Norm
architecture and then pre-norm is just
flip them around
so I've actually done some testing with
prenorm and post norm and the original
Transformer paper turned out to be
quite actually a lot better
at least for training very small
language models if you're training
bigger ones it might be different
but
essentially we're just going to go by
the rules that we use in here so add a
norm we're not going to do norm and add
we're doing add a norm in this video
specifically because it works better and
we just don't want to break any of the
rules and go outside of it because then
that starts to get confusing and
actually if you watch the Android
carpathy lecture on building gpts from
scratch
he uh he actually implemented it in the
pre-norm way so normalize then add so
yeah based on my experience what I've
done on my computer here
is the post Norm architecture Works
quite better so that's why we're going
to use it
we're going to do add then normalize
so then
we essentially feed this into a feed
forward Network which we covered earlier
and then
uh how did it go
we have a yeah I'm sorry encoder we do
we do a
residual connection from here to here
and then another residual connection
from like outside of our feed forward
Network so each time we're doing some
other things like some you know some
computation blocks in here we're gonna
have a rest connection
same with our feed forward rest
connection
and then of course the output from here
which is when it access it's going to
feed into the next encoder block if it's
not the last encoder so this one is
going to do all this it's going to feed
into that one it's going to do the same
thing feed it into this one gonna feed
into that one and then the output of
this is going to feed into each of these
decoders all the same information
and yeah so that's
a little bit scoped in as to what these
encoders look like so now that you know
what the encoder looks like what the
feed forward looks like we're going to
go into multi-head attention sort of the
premise
sort of the highlight of the Transformer
architecture and why it's so important
so
multihead attention we call it
multi-head attention because there are a
bunch of these different heads learning
different semantic info from a new
unique perspective so let's say you have
10 different people looking at the same
book if you have 10 different people
let's say they're all reading
um let's say they're all reading the
same Harry Potter book okay
these these different people they might
have you know different cognitive
abilities they might have different IQs
they might have been raised in different
ways so they might interpret things
differently they might they might look
at little things in that book and their
their mind will or they'll they'll
imagine you know different scenarios
different environments from the book
and essentially why this is so valuable
is because we don't just want to have
one person just one perspective on this
we want to have a bunch of different
heads in parallel looking at this
looking at this same piece of data
because they're all going to capture
different things about it and keep in
mind each of these heads each of these
heads in parallel these different
perspectives
they have different learnable parameters
so they're not all the same one looking
at this piece of data they're actually
uh they're they all have different
learnable parameters so you have a bunch
of these at the same time learning
different things and that's why it's so
powerful
so
this uh this scale dot product attention
runs in parallel which means we can
scale that to the GPU which is very
useful
let's go to touch on that anything with
the GPU that you can accelerate is just
an automatic win because
you know
parallelism is great in machine learning
why not have parallelism right if it's
just going to be running the CPU what's
the point
that's why we love gpus
um
anyways yeah so you're gonna have these
different you're gonna have these things
that are called keys queries and values
I'll touch on those in a second here
because
Keys queries and values sort of point to
self-attention which is literally the
entire point of the Transformer
Transformer wouldn't really mean
anything without self-attention so I'll
touch on those in a second here and
we'll actually delve deeper once we hit
this sort of block
but yeah you have these Keys queries and
values they go into scale dot product
detention so a bunch of these running in
parallel
and then you concatenate the results
from all these different heads running
in parallel you have all these different
people you concatenate all of them you
generalize it and then you apply a
transformation to a linear
transformation to pretty much summarize
that and then
and then do your add a norm and pay
forward Network so
that's what's going on in multi-head
attention you're just doing a bunch of
self-tensions in parallel concatenating
and then continuing on with this part
so
scale dot product attention what is that
let's just start from the ground up here
so you have we'll just go from left to
right so you have your keys queries and
values what do your keys do well a key
is let's just say you have a token in a
sentence okay so if you have a
let me just scroll down here to a good
example
so
self-attention
uses Keys queries and values
self-attention helps identify
which of these tokens in a sentence in
any given sentence are more important
and how much attention you should pay to
each of those characters or words
whatever you're using we'll just we'll
just use words to to make it easier to
understand for this for the purpose of
this video
but essentially imagine imagine you have
um
these two sentences here so you have let
me bring out my little piece of text
so you have
oh
that didn't work
so imagine you have
server can I have the check
and then you have
then you have looks like I crashed the
server
so I mean both of these have the word
server in them but they mean different
things server meaning like the waiter or
the waitress or whoever it is whoever is
uh billing you at the end of your
restaurant visit and it looks like I
crashed the server is like oh there's
actually a server running in the cloud
not like a person that's billing me but
an actual server that's maybe running a
video game
and these are two different things so
what attention can do is it can actually
identify which words to get attention
here so it can say
server can I have the check
can I have so it's maybe you're looking
for something you're looking for the
check and then server is like oh well in
this in this particular sequence or in
this in the sentiment of this sentence
here
server is specifically tied to this one
meaning maybe a human someone at a
restaurant
and then crash crash the server crashes
crash is going to get a very high
attention score because
you don't normally crash crash a server
at a restaurant that doesn't
particularly make sense so
when you have different words like this
what self-attention will do is it will
learn which one of the which which words
in the sentence are actually more
important and which should which words
should it pay more attention to
so that's really all that's going on
here and K the key
is essentially going to emit a different
uh it's going to emit
a little tensor for each of these words
here saying you know what do I contain
and then clearly is going to say
what am I looking for
so what's going to happen is if these
it's like let's say server it's going to
look for things like you know check or
crashed so if it sees crashed then that
means the key and the query are going to
multiply and it's going to get a very
high attention score
but if you had something like the and
the it's like oh the kid does literally
like almost any sentence so that doesn't
mean much we're not going to pay
attention to those words so that's going
to get a very low attention score
and all attention is is you're just dot
product dot producting these vectors
together so you get a key and a query
you dot product them we already went
over dot products uh in this course
before
and then
all you do here and this is a little a
little bit of a confusing part is you
just scale you scale it by one over the
square root of the of the length of a
row in the quiz keys or queries Matrix
otherwise known as DK
so
let's say we have you know our our key
and our query these are all going to be
the same length by the way let's say our
keys is
you know maybe
maybe our keys is going to be like 10
characters long our our cues are going
to be 10 characters long as well
so it's going to do 1 over the square
root of 10.
if that makes sense
and so that's just that's just
essentially a way of preventing
uh uh these dot products from exploding
right we want to scale them because as
we have uh as it in as the length of it
increases so will the ending dot product
because there's more of these to
multiply so we pretty much just want to
scale it by using an inverse square root
and that'll just help us with scaling
make sure nothing explodes
uh in unnecessary ways
and then the next little important part
is using torch.rill which I imagine we
went over in our examples here
Trail
yeah
so
you can see that it's a it's a diagonal
it's a left triangular Matrix of ones
and these aren't going to be ones in our
self-attention here in our torque dot
Trail or masking
what this is going to be is
uh
the scores at each time step combination
of scores at each time step
so
if we've only gone you know if we're
only looking at the first time step we
should not have access to the rest of
things or else that would be cheating we
shouldn't be allowed to look ahead
because we haven't actually produced
these yet we need to produce these
before we can put them into perspective
and you know put a weight on them
so we're going to set all these to zero
and then we go to the next time step
okay so now we've we've just generated
this one we haven't generated these yet
so we can't look at them and then as we
go more and more as as the time step
increases we know more and more context
about all these tokens so
that's all that's doing mask attention
is pretty much just saying we don't want
to look into the future we want to only
guess with what we currently know in our
current time step and everything before
it
you you can't jump into the future you
can only look at what happened in the
past and do stuff based on that right
same thing applies to life you can't
really skip to the Future and say hey if
you do this you're going to be a
billionaire no that would be cheating
you're not allowed to do that you can
only look at the mistakes you made and
say how can I become a billionaire based
on all these other mistakes that I made
how can I become as close to perfect as
possible
which no one I can ever be perfect but
that's my little analogy for the day
so that's Mass attention pretty much
just not letting us skip time steps so
that's fun let's continue two more
little things I want to touch on before
I jump forward here so these Keys
queries and values each of these are
learned through a linear transformation
just an NN dot linear
is applied and that's how we get our
keys queries and values so that's that's
just a little touching there if you're
wondering how do we get those it's just
an nn.linear transformation
uh and then as for our masking we don't
actually apply this all the time you
might have seen right here
we have multi-head attention let's add
attention and then masked multihead
tension so this Mass detention isn't
used all the time it's only used
actually one out of the three attentions
we have per layer
so I'll give you I'll give you a little
bit more information about that as we
you know progress more and more into the
architecture and as we
as we learn more about it I'm not going
to dive into that quite yet though so
let's just continue on with what's going
on so we have a soft Max
and why softmax important
well
I actually mentioned earlier softmax is
not commonly used as a normalization
method but here we're actually using
softmax to normalize
so when you have all of these uh
when you have all these you know
attention scores
essentially what the softmax is doing is
it's going to exponentiate and normalize
all these so all of the attention scores
that have scored high like would be 50
to 90 or whatever it is those are going
to take a massive effect in that entire
uh attention
I guess tensor if you want to call it
that
and that's important well it's it's it
might not seem important but it's
essentially just giving the model more
confidence as to which tokens matter
more
so for example
if we just did a normal normalization
we would have words like server and
crash and then server and check
and then
you would you would just know you know a
decent amount about those those would be
pay attention to a decent amount because
they're because they multiply together
quite well but if you soft Max those
then it's like those are almost the only
characters that matter
so it's looking at the context of those
two and then we're sort of filling in
like we're learning about the rest of
the sentence based on just the uh
sentiment of those attention scores
because they're so high priority because
they multiplied together to such a high
degree we want to emphasize them and
then basically let the model learn more
about which words matter more together
so that's pretty much just what the
softmax does it increases our confidence
in attention
and then a matrix multiply well we go
back to our V here and this is a value
so essentially what this is is just a
linear transformation and we apply this
on our uh we apply this on our inputs
and it's just going to have some value
about you know
what exactly those tokens are and after
we've gotten all of our Attention our
softmax everything done
it's just going to multiply the original
values by everything we've gotten so far
so that we don't have any information
that's really lost or we don't have
anything scrambled just that we have
like a general idea of okay these are
actually all the tokens we have and then
these are uh which ones we found
interesting the attention scores
so yeah we have an output which is a
blend of input Vector values and a
tension placed on each token and that's
pretty much what's happening in scale
dot product attention in parallel so we
have a bunch of these that are just
happening at the same time
many of these happening at the same time
and yeah so that's what attention is
that's what feed forward networks are
that's what residual connections are
uh
and yeah and then so after this after
we've you know fed these into our our
decoders
we get an output we apply a linear
transformation to summarize
soft Max probabilities
and then we generate based on that based
on everything that we learned
and
actually what I didn't quite write a lot
about was the decoder
so what I'm actually going to talk about
next is something I didn't fill in yet
which is why
why the heck do we use Mass attention
here but not in these places so why the
heck do we have multi-head attention
here all that attention here but Mass
attention here so why is this well the
purpose of the encoder is to pretty much
learn
the present past and future and put that
into a vector representation for the
decoder that's what the encoder does so
it's okay if we look into the future and
understand tokens that way because we're
technically not cheating we're just
learning the different attention scores
uh
and yeah we're just using that to help
us predict based on you know what the
sentence looks like but not explicitly
giving it away just giving it an idea of
you know what to look for type of thing
and then
use Mass attention here because well we
don't want to look ahead we just want to
we want to look at the present and the
past
and
later on so see we're not we're not
given anything explicit here we're not
given anything yet so we want to make
some raw guesses they're good they're
not going to be very good guesses at
first but we want to make some broad
guesses
and then later on we can feed these the
added and normalized gases into
into this next mod that attention which
which isn't masked and then we can use
this Max multi-headed tension with the
vector representation given by the
encoder and then we can sort of do more
useful things with that rather than just
being forced to guess you know raw
attention scores and then being judged
for that we can sort of introduce more
uh more and more elements in this
decoder block to help us learn more
meaningful things so
we start off with taking this
Mass multi-head attention
and then combining that
with our we then afterwards we do a
multi-headed tension with the vector
representation from the encoder and then
we can make decisions on that so that's
kind of why that that works this way uh
if I if you don't think I explain it
like amazingly well you can totally just
you know ask gpt4 about it or GPT 3.5
and get a pretty decent answer but
that's how that works and uh yeah
another thing that I kind of wanted to
point out here is these linear
Transformations that you see
uh I mean there's there's a lot of them
in the uh what is it scale dot product
detention so you have your linears for
your value or key value and key query
and values so these linears as well as
the one up here linears are great for
just expanding or shrinking a bunch of
important info
into something easier to work with so if
you have a bunch of lar if you have a
large Vector containing a bunch of info
learned from this scale.product
attention
you can you can sort of just compress
that into something more manageable
through a linear transformation and
that's essentially what's Just Happening
Here for the softmax as well as in our
scale dot product attention here for
these uh linear Transformations from our
inputs to uh quick Keys queries and
values that's all that's happening uh
yeah if you want to read more about you
know linear Transformations the
importance of them you can totally go
out of your way to do that but that's
just sort of a brief summary as to why
they're important just shrinking or
expanding factors so that's sort of a
brief overview on how Transformers work
however in this course we will not be
building the Transformer architecture
we'll be building something called a GPT
which you're probably familiar with and
GPT stands for generatively pre-trained
Transformer or generate a pre-trained
Transformer one of the two
and pretty much what this is it's pretty
close to the Transformer this
architecture here except it only adopts
the decoder blocks and it takes away
this multi-headed tension here so all
we're doing is we're removing the
encoder
as well as what the encoder plugs into
so all we have left is just some inputs
our Max multi-headed tension our post
Norm architecture
and then right after this we're not
going to a non-mask model head attention
but rather to a feed forward Network and
then a post Norm so that's all it is
it's just one two three four that's all
it's going to look like that's all the
blocks are going to be
uh it is still important to understand
the Transformer architecture itself
because you might need that in the
future and it is sort of a good practice
in language modeling to
have a grasp on and to understand you
know why we use mass multi-attention in
the decoder and why we don't use it in
the encoder and stuff like that so
anyways
we're going to go ahead and build this
uh if if you need to look back if
something wasn't quite clear definitely
skip back a few seconds or a few minutes
through the video and just make sure you
clarify everything up to this point uh
but yeah
I'm going to go over some more math on
the side here and just some other little
uh little widgets we're going to need
for building the decoder GPT
architecture so let's go ahead and do
that before we actually jump into
building the Transformer rather building
the gbt from scratch what I want to do
is Linger on self-attention for a little
bit or rather just the attention
mechanism and the matrix multiplication
behind it and why it works
so I'm going to use whiteboard to
illustrate this
so we're going to go ahead and draw out
a uh we'll just use maybe a a four token
sequence here of words my dog has please
okay
so
we're going to highlight which words are
probably going to end up correlating
together or at the attention mechanism
is going to multiply them together to a
high amount based on what it learns
about those tokens this is what this is
so I'm going to help us illustrate that
and what the
GPT is going to see sort of from the
inside what it looks like from the
inside
so
I'm gonna go ahead and draw this out
here
just make a table here
we'll give it
four of these
and drill a little line through the
middle
my drawing might not be perfect but it's
definitely better than on paper
so cool
we have this
we have
my
oh
let me go here
dog
has
please
and then my
my dog
let's delete that
my dog has
cool
so to what degree are these going to
interact well my and my I mean it
doesn't really give away that much it's
only just the start so maybe this will
interact to a low amount
and then you have my end dog these might
interact to a medium amount because it's
like your dog so we might go
you might go medium like that
and then mine has well that doesn't give
away too much so maybe that'll be low
and then Mayan flees it's like oh that
doesn't really mean much my fleas that
doesn't really make sense maybe we'll
have it interact to a low amount
and then
uh these would be the same thing so uh
my end dog so be medium
and then has and has would be low
and then Mayan fleas would also be low
and then you have dog and dog so these
might interact to a low amount they're
the same word so we'll just uh forget
about that and then we have
uh dog has so these might interact to a
medium amount
dog has the dog has something
and then dog and fleas these might
interact to a high amount because
they're associating the dog with
something else meaning fleas
we have has and dog these would interact
with the same amount so medium and then
has and has be
uh probably to a low amount
and then we could do loaf or we could do
um what was it high for this one as well
fleas and dog
so these will interact to a high amount
and then we have has and fleas so uh
these could interact maybe a medium
amount
medium and then plays in place which
would be low
so what you get I'll just highlight this
in I'll just highlight this in green
here so you get
all the medium and high attention scores
you'd have your
medium here medium here High
medium medium high
medium and medium so you can see these
are sort of symmetrical and this is what
the attention map will look like of
course there's going to be some scaling
going on here based on the amount of
actual attentions heads we have running
in parallel but that's besides the point
really what's going on here is
the network is going to learn how to
place
the right attention scores because
attention is simply being used to
generate tokens that's that's how the
that's how the GPT works it's using
attention to generate tokens
so we can make those sort of attention
scores how they're placed we can make
those learnable through all of the like
embeddings like everything we have in
the entire network can make sure that we
place effective attention scores and to
make sure that they're measured properly
so obviously I didn't quantify these
very well like not with floating Point
numbers but this is sort of the premise
of how it works and how we want the
model to look at different tokens and
how they relate to one another so
that's what the attention mechanism
looks like under the hood so this is
what the actual GPT or decoder only
Transformer architecture looks like
and yeah so I'm just going to go through
this step by step here and then we can
hopefully jump into some of the math and
code behind how this works
so we have our inputs embeddings and
positional encodings we have only
decoder blocks and then some linear
transformation and then pretty much just
we do some soft Max probability
distribution we sample from those and
then we start just generating some
output and then we compare those to our
inputs and see how off they were
optimized from that
and each of these decoder blocks we have
our all data tension res connections
food forward Network consists of a
linear relay linear in that order
and then another rest connection
in each of these multi-added tensions we
have
multiple heads running in parallel and
each of these heads is going to take a
key query and value
these are all learnable linear
transformations
and
we're going to basically dot product the
key and query together
concatenate these results
and do a little transformation to sort
of summarize it afterwards and then what
actually goes on in the dot product
tension is just a DOT product we have
the key and query the scaling to prevent
these values from exploding to prevent
the vanishing gradient problem and then
we have our masking to make sure that
these to make sure the model isn't
looking ahead and cheating
and then soft Max Matrix multiply we
output that and then kind of fill in the
blank there so cool this is a little bit
pretty much the Transformer architecture
a little bit dumbed down a little a
little smaller in complexity to actually
understand but that's kind of the
premise of what's going on here
so still implements a self-attention
mechanism
so as you can see now I am currently on
my MacBook
uh M2 Chip I'm not going to go into the
specs of why it's important but really
quick I'm just going to show you how I
SSH onto my other PC
so I go SSH
just like that and then I type in my
ipv4 address
and then I just get a simple password
Here password that I've memorized
cool so now I'm on my desktop computer
and this is the command prompt that I
use for it so awesome I'm going to go
ahead and go into the free code Camp a
little directory I have so CD desktop
CD python testing
and then here I'm actually going to
activate my Cuda virtual environment
not accelerates I'm gonna go Cuda
activate cool and then I'm going to go
CD into free code cam GPT course awesome
so now if I actually do code on here
like this to open up my vs code it
doesn't do that so there's another
little way I have to do this and you
have to go into vs code
go into the little remote Explorer here
and then you can simply connect so I'm
just going to connect to the current
window itself
there's an extension you need for this
called openssh server I think it's what
it's called
and simply the same password I used in
the command prompt
correctly
awesome so now it's SSH into my computer
upstairs
and I'm just going to open the little
editor in here
nice so you can see that it looks just
like that that's wonderful
so now I'm going to open this in the
Jupiter notebook
actually
desktop here see python
python testing Cuda Scripts
activate
CD free codepam GPT course and then code
click that and it will open
perfect
how wonderful is that I've already done
a little bit of this here but uh
we're gonna jump into exactly how we can
build up this Transformer or gbt
architecture in the code itself
so
I'm going to pop over to my Jupiter
notebook in here
cool and now this little address I'm
going to paste that into
my browser
awesome
so
we have this gptv one
Jupiter notebook
so what I've actually done is I've done
some importations here so I've I've
imported all of these python
importations all the hyper parameters
that we used from before
I've imported the data loader I've
imported the tokenizer
uh the training valve splits at the get
batch function estimate loss just
everything that we're going to need and
it's all a neatly organized little code
blocks
so awesome now what well let's go ahead
and continue here
with the actual upgrading
from the very top level so I remember I
actually showed and you can skip back to
this I actually showed the architecture
of the GPT
sort of lined out in I guess a little
sketch a little sketch that I did and
all we're going to do is pretty much
build up from the high level the high
high level General architecture down to
the technical stuff down to the very
root dot product attention that we're
going to be doing here so I'm going to
go ahead and start off with this
gbt language model which I just renamed
I replaced uh Bagram with
gbt here so that's all we're doing and
I'm going to add some add some little
code bits and just walk through step by
step what we're doing so
let's do that so great we're going for
next we're going to talk about these
positional encodings so I go back to the
paper here rather this architecture
we initially have our tokenized inputs
and then we give
uh we give them embedding so token
embeddings and then a positional
encoding so this positional encoding
going back to the attention paper is
right here
so all it does is every uh even token
index we apply this function and then
every odd token index we apply this
function you don't really need to know
what's what it's doing other than the
fact that these are the different sine
and cosine functions that it uses to
apply positional encodings to the
tokenized inputs
so every
so on our first index or whatever let's
say we have Hello World okay there's
five characters here H will be index
zero so it'll get an even uh encoding
function and then e will be odd since
it's index one so it'll get this one and
then L we'll get this the next I'll look
at this and then
uh or I don't know if I messed up that
order but essentially it just iterates
and it goes back and forth between those
applying these fixed functions and the
thing is with fixed functions is that
they don't actually learn about the data
at all because they're fixed so another
way we could do this would be using
and then dot embedding which is what we
use for the token embedding so I'm going
to go ahead and implement this here in
our gptv1 script
so I'm going to go ahead and add on this
line
self dot positional and self-top
position embedding table and a DOT
embedding block size so the block size
is the length or the the sequence length
which in our case is going to be eight
so there's going to be eight tokens
and
this means we're going to have eight
different indices and each one is going
to be of size n dot embed and this is a
new parameter I actually want to add
here so and a DOT embed will not only be
used in positional embedding
but it will also be used in our token
embedding because when we actually store
information about the tokens we want
that to be in a very large Vector so not
necessarily a probability distribution
or what we what we were using before in
the bigram language model
but rather a really large vector
or a list you could think about it as a
bunch of different attributes
that are about a character so maybe you
know
A and E would be pretty close because
they're both vowels versus like e and z
would be very different because Z is not
a very common letter and E is the most
common letter in the alphabet
so we pretty much just want to have
vectors to differentiate these tokens to
place some semantic meaning on them
and
anyways that's a little talk about what
token embedding table is going to do
when we add n dot embed and then
positional embedding table is just the
same thing but instead of each character
having its own thing each uh each letter
index in the input is going to have its
own embedding so I can go and add this
up here the N underscore embed and we
can just make this maybe 384. so 384 is
quite huge
it's maybe a little too big for your PC
but we'll see in a second
so
what this is going to do is it's going
to have a giant Vector it's going to be
like I don't know we could say like
embedding I say like embedding vector
and then it would be like be like this
and you would have a bunch of different
attributes so like 0.1
0.2
0.8
1.1 right except instead of 4 this is
384 elements long and each of these is
just going to store a tiny little
attribute about that token
so
let's say we maybe had like a two
dimensional and we were using a word so
if we had sad
versus happy
sad might be
sad might be 0.1
and then
0.8 or 0.8
whereas happy because that would be that
would be maybe the the positivity of
what it's saying and then 0.8 would be
is it showing some sort of emotion which
is a lot right it's 80 emotion and 0.1
of maybe positive sentiment
and then if we had 0.9 would be happy
because it's it's happy it's very good
and then 0.8 is emotional because
they're sort of the same on the
emotional level
uh but yeah so this is what our
embedding vectors are pretty much
describing and all this hyper parameter
is concerned with is how long that
Vector actually is
so anyways let's continue with the gbt
language model class so the next bit I
like to talk about is how many decoder
layers we have
so in here
let's just say we have four decoder
layers all right so we have four of
these it's going to go through this one
and then this one and then this one then
this one this is all happening
sequentially so we could actually make a
little sequential neural network with
four decoder layers so I'm actually
going to add this in
and then a little bit extra code which
I'll explain in a second here
so this self
dot blocks is how many decoder blocks we
have running sequentially or layers
blocks and layers can be used
interchangeably in this context but yeah
we have an N dot sequential and this
asterisk is pretty much saying
we're going to repeat this right here
for how many end layer is and then
layers another hyper parameter we're
going to add
we go n underscore layer we go equals
four okay
so n underscore layer equals four that
means it's going to make four of these
uh I guess blocks or layers sequentially
it's going to make four of them uh and
this little block thing we're going to
build on top of this in a second here
where we're going to make an actual
block class and I'm going to explain
what that does uh but for now this is
going to be some temporary code as long
as you understand that this is what uh
this is how we create our four layers
our four decoder layers that's all you
need to know for now I'm going to move
more into this block later
as for this self dot layer Norm final
this is the file final final layer Norm
all this is going to do is we're just
simply going to add this to the end of
our Network here
uh
just simply at the end here and also
going to do is just going to help the
model converge better layer Norms are
super useful
uh
and yeah so you'll see more how that
works I'll actually remove it later on
and we'll actually compare and see how
good uh it actually does and you can you
can totally go out of your way to
experiment with different normalizations
and see how well the layer Norm
helps the model perform or how well the
loss sort of converges over time when
you put the layer Norm in different
places
so
let's go back here and now we have this
uh end here which is the language
I believe this is language modeling head
or something again this is this is what
Andrea karpath used I'm assuming that
means language modeling head
but pretty much all we're doing is we're
just projecting we're doing this final
transformation here this final uh little
linear layer here
from all of these sequential decoder
outputs
and we're just going to transform that
to
something that the softmax can work with
so we have our layer Norm afterwards to
sort of normalize help the model
converge after all these after all this
computation we're going to feed that
into a linear layer
to make it I guess a soft Max
workable so the stop Max can work with
it
and
yeah so we're just simply projecting it
from an embed which is the vector length
that we get from our decoder
and
uh
and this vocab size so the vocab size is
going to essentially give up a little
probability distribution on each token
that we have or the vocabulary
so anyways I'm going to
make this back to normal here and we're
going to just apply this to the forward
pass so a little thing I wanted to add
on to this positional embedding
or rather just the idea of embeddings
versus the fixed definite function of
that the sign ins sinusoidal functions
and the cosine functions that we used
here
these are both actually used in practice
the reason I said we're going to use
embeddings is because we just want it to
be more oriented out around our data
however in practice sinusoidal encodings
are used in base Transformer models
whereas learned emitting is what we're
using
are used in variants like gbt and we are
building a GPT so we're probably going
to find better performance from
learningable embeddings and this is just
something that the experts do it's a
little practice that experts do when
they're building Transformer models
versus variants like gbts so that's just
a little background on why we're using
learnable embeddings so now let's
continue
with the forward pass here so I'm going
to paste in some more code
and let me just make sure this is
formatted properly cool
we have this token embedding which is
our token embedding table we take an idx
we get our token embedding here
then what we do with this positional
embedding table so we have this torch
dial range we make sure this is on the
Cuda device
the GPU device so it's in parallel
and all this is going to do is it's
going to look at how long is T and let's
say t is T is our block size
but he's going to be eight so all it's
going to do is give us eight indices
it's going to be like 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7.
there's eight of those and we're
essentially just going to give each of
those
uh each of those indices a different
uh a different
an embedding vector
for each of those indices just a little
lookup table and uh that's what that is
so all we do now is it's actually quite
simple and this is a very efficient way
to do it is you just add these two
together
so torch broadcasting rules which you
might want to look into I'll actually
search that up right now uh torch also
or search broadcasting semantics
Pi torch
broadcasting I cannot spell
broadcasting semantics
so
these are a little bit funky when you
look at them the first time but pretty
much these are just rules about how you
can do arithmetic operations and just
operations in general to tensors so
tensors are like you think of matrices
where it's like a two by two tensors can
be the same thing but they could be like
a a two by two by two or a Two by Two by
Two by Two by Two by Two by Two whatever
Dimension you want to have there
and pretty much it's just rules about
how you can
uh
have two of those weirdly
shaped tensors and do things to to them
so there's some rules here I would
advise you familiarize yourself with
these even play around with it if you
want just for a few minutes and just get
an idea for which like just try to
multiply tensors together
and see which ones throw errors and
which ones don't so it's a good idea to
understand how broadcasting rules work
obviously This this term is a little
fancy and it's like oh that that's like
a crazy Advanced term
uh not really just it's pretty much just
some rules about how you're multiplying
these really weirdly shaped tensors so
yeah
uh anyways if we go back to here
uh
we are allowed to broadcast these we're
allowed to actually add them together so
the positional embedding and the token
embedding we get X from this which is a
b by T by C shape
so now
what we can do with these is we can
actually feed it in to the GPT or I
guess sort of a transformer network if
you want to say that
so we have these embeddings and
positional encodings we add these
together and then we feed them into our
sequential Network so how are we doing
this
well we go self dot blocks which is up
here
and we essentially just feed an X which
is literally exactly what happens here
we have our tokenized inputs we've got
our embeddings and our positional
encodings through learnable embeddings
we add them together and then we feed
them into the network directly
so that's all that's happening here
and that's how we're feeding an X which
is the output of these
then after all of the this is like way
after we've gotten through all of these
Trend uh all these GPT layers or blocks
we do this final layer norm and then
this linear transformation to get it to
a soft Max
to get it to essentially probabilities
that we can feed into our stop Max
function and then other than that this
forward pass is exactly the same other
than this little block of code here
so if this makes sense so far that is
absolutely amazing let's continue I'm
actually going to add a little bit of
in practice
some some little white initializations
that we should be using in our language
model
in a module subclass
so
I'm going to go over a little bit of
math here but this is just really
important for practice and to make sure
that your model does not fail in the
training process this is very important
it's going to be a little a little funky
on the on the conceptualizing but yeah
bring out some pen and paper and do some
math with me we've built up some of
these initial gbt language model
architecture and before we continue
building more of it and the other
functions some of the master that's
going on in the parallelization that's
going on in the script I want to show
you some of the math that we're going to
use to initialize the weights of the
model to help it train and converge
better
so
there's this new thing that I want to
introduce called standard deviation and
this is used in intermediate level
mathematics
the symbol essentially looks like this
population standard deviation
so
n so the size so it's just going to be
an array the length of the array
and then x i we iterate over each value
so accept position zero X at position
one except position two
and then this U here is the mean
so essentially we're going to
iterate over each element we're going to
subtract it by the mean we're going to
square that and then keep adding all
these squared results together and then
once we get the sum of that we're going
to
subtract or we're going to divide this
by the number of elements there are and
then once we get this result we're going
to square root that
so this this symbol here might might
also look a little bit unfamiliar and
let me just illustrate this out for you
as we go to our whiteboard and this e
looks like
looks like that let's just say we were
to put in x
I like that
and our array let's just say for
instance our array
is 0.1
0.2 0.3 so what would the result of this
be well if we look at each element
iteratively add them together so 0.1
plus 0.2 plus 0.3 well we get 0.6 from
that so this would essentially
be equal to
zero point
six
that's what that equals we just add each
of these up together or we do whatever
this is iteratively
whatever this element is we iterate over
the number of elements we have in some
arbitrary array or
vector or list or whatever you want to
call it
and then we just sort of look at what's
going on here and we can do some basic
arithmetic stuff
so let's walk through and let's walk
through a few examples just to
illustrate to you what the results look
like based on the inputs here
so I'm going to go back to my whiteboard
we're going to draw a little line here
just to separate this and let's go down
so
I want to calculate the standard
deviation and do standard deviation
of
and then we'll just make some random
array negative
0.38 so
negative 0.38
0.52
and then 2.48
cool
so we have this array this is three
elements so that means n is going to be
equal to three let me drag this over
here so n is the number of elements so n
is going to be equal to 3.
our mean
well our mean is just we add all these
up together and then we average them so
our mean
is going to be equal to
let's just say 0 on negative 0.38
plus 0.52 plus 2.48
and then divide by 3.
and the answer to this I did the math
ahead of time is the problem is it is
literally 0.873 repeated but we're just
going to put 0.87 for simplicity's sake
cool so the mean of this is 0.87 and N
is equal to 3. now we can start doing
some of the other math so
we have this uh we have this o has a
cool line
and we do
square root
1 over
n which is equal to 3 and then we
multiply this
by
Sigma that's what this six uh that's
what this symbol is because that's Sigma
that's the name for it
and then we go
the X
I
minus
and then our mean of zero
point
eight
seven
apologies for the sloppy writing
and then we square that so cool let me
drag this out
awesome
so
let's just do this step by step here so
the first one is going to be
0.38 so we have
zero point or negative
0.38
and we're going to do minus the mean
here so minus 0.87
and I'm just going to wrap all this in
Brackets so that we don't miss anything
I'm going to wrap it in Brackets
and then just Square it and see what we
get after so I'm just going to write all
these out then we can do the
calculations so next up we have 0.52
minus 0.7
square that
and then next up we have
point
four eight minus 0.87
and then we square that as well
so awesome what is the result of this
the result of negative 0.38 minus
0.87 squared is 1.57
the result of this line
is 0.12 these again these are all
approximations they're not super spot on
we're just doing this to understand
what's going on here
just to overview the function not for
precision
then the next one is going to be 2.59
and you can double check all these
calculations if you'd like I have done
these preemptively so
that is that
and now from here all we have to do is
add each of these together so 1.57 plus
0.12 plus 2.59 divided by three
is
1.57 plus 0.12 plus 2.59 all that
divided by 3.
is going to be equal to 1.42 and then
keep in mind we also have to square root
this so the square root of that
is going to be 0 1.19 approximately
we'll just add
this guy ahead of it a little
approximation thing
and so that's what the standard
deviation of
this array is 0 negative 0.38 0.52 2.48
the standard deviation is approximately
1.19 awesome let's do another example
so let's say
I want to do the standard deviation of
you know zero point
four eight zero point five
zero I guess
0.52
cool so there's a little pattern here
just goes up by 0.02 each time
and you're going to see why this is
vastly different than the other example
so let's walk through this
so first of all we have n
n is equal to 3. cool
what does our mean
our mean
well if you do our mean or mean it's 0.5
if you do 0.48 plus this plus that
divided by 3 that's going to be 0.5
and if you're good with numbers you'll
probably already be able to do this in
your head but that's okay if not
next up we're going to do this in the
formula so
what what are these what do these
iterations look like so
zero point or let's just do these in
Brackets the old way
minus zero points 0.5 squared
the next one is
0.5 minus 0.5
squared which we already know is zero
and then this one is 0.52 minus 0.5
squared so the result of 0.48 minus 0.5
squared and we'll just write equals here
is going to be
approximately
0.02 so squared so that would be 0.004
like that so I'll make this not actually
overlap
0.004 and then this one we obviously
know would be zero because 0.5 minus 0.5
that's 0 then you square zero still the
same thing
and then this one is
um
0.0004 as well
so when we add these two together we're
going to get 0 0.0008
just like that and then if we divide
them by 3 or whatever n is
then we end up getting
0.00026 repeating so I'll just write two
six six like that
and so all we have to do at this point
is just find the square root of this and
uh
we'll do this let's do square root of
0.0026 approximately
and
that's going to be equal to about 0.0163
so that is our standard deviation of
both of these arrays here so 0.048 and
then 5 0.5 and then 0.52 our standard
deviation is
.0163 so very small and then we have
negative 0.38.52 and 2.48 we get a
standard deviation of 1.19 so you can
see that these numbers are vastly
different one is like
one is literally
a hundred times greater than the other
so
the reason for this is because these
numbers are super diverse they uh
I guess another way you could think of
them is that they they stretch out very
far from the mean
so this essentially means when you're
initializing your parameters
that if you have some outliers then your
network is gonna your network is going
to be funky because it's
the learning process just messed up
because you have outliers and it's not
just learning the right way it's
supposed to
whereas if you had way too small of a
standard deviation from your initial
parameters like in here but maybe even
smaller so let's say they were all 0.5
right then all of your neurons would
effectively be the same and they would
all learn the same pattern so then you
would have no learning done
so one would either be your learning is
super super unstable and you have
outliers that are just learning very
distinct things and not really uh
not really not really letting other
neurons get opportunities to learn or
rather other parameters to learn uh you
yeah if you have a lot of diversity you
just have outliers and then if you have
uh
no diversity at all then essentially
nothing is learned and your network is
useless so all we want to do is make
sure that our standard deviation is
balanced and stable so that the training
process can learn effective things so
each neuron can learn a little bit
so you can see here this would probably
be an okay standard deviation if these
were some parameters because they're a
little bit different than each other
they're not all like super super close
to the same and yeah so essentially what
this looks like in a code here is the
following so you don't actually need to
memorize what this does as it's just
used in practice
by professionals but essentially what
this does is it initializes our weights
around certain standard deviations so
here we set it to .02 which is pretty
much the same as what we had in here so
uh point
uh yeah this one's a little bit off in
the standard deviation we set here but
essentially we're just making sure that
our away our weights are initialized
properly and uh you don't have to
memorize this at all it's just using
practice and it's going to help our
training converge better so as long as
you understand that we we can apply some
initializations on our weights uh that's
all that really matters so cool let's
move on to the next part of our gbt
architecture so awesome we finished this
gbt language model class everything's
pretty much done here we did our init we
did some weight initializations and we
did our forward pass so awesome that's
all done now let's move on to the next
which is the block class
so what is block
well if we go back to this diagram each
of these decoder blocks is a block so
we're pretty much just gonna fill in
this Gap here our GPD language model has
these two where we get our tokenized
inputs and then we do some
Transformations and a soft Max after
and essentially we're just filling in
this Gap here and then we're going to
build out and just sort of Branch out
until it's completely built
so let's go ahead and build these blocks
here what does this look like that's
what this does
so we have our knit we have a forward
pass as per usual
and knit
and a forward pass as seen in the GPT
language model class though all of them
are going to look like this forward and
an init
so the init is going to just initialize
some things it's going to initialize
some some Transformations and some
things that we're going to do in the
forward pass that's all it's doing
so what do we do first well we have this
new head size parameter introduced so
head size is the number of features that
each head will be capturing in our
multi-hat attention so all the heads in
parallel how many features are each of
them capturing so we do that by dividing
n in bed by n head so n head is the
number of heads we have and embed is a
number of features we have
or we're capturing so 384 features
divided by four heads so each head is
going to be capturing
96 features hence head size
so
next up we have self.sa which is just
short for self-attention we do a
multi-head attention we pass in our n
head and our head size and you'll see
how this how these parameters fit in
later once we build up this multi-head
attention class
so cool now we have a feed forward which
is as explained just in the
diagram here our feed forward is just
this which we're actually going to build
out next
and we have some and we have two layer
norms and these are just for the Post
Norm pre-norm architecture that we could
Implement here in this case it's going
to be post Norm just because I found
that it converges better for this for
this course and the data that we're
using and just the model parameters and
whatnot it just works better
so
also that is the original architecture
that we use in the tension paper so you
might have seen that they do an add a
norm rather than a Norman add so
anyways we've initialized all of these
cool so we have head size self-attention
feed forward and then two layer norms
so in our forward pass we do our
self-attention first let's actually go
back to here so we do our our self
attention then add a norm then a feed
forward and then add a norm again
so
what does this look like self-attention
add a norm feed forward add a norm cool
so we're doing an ad so we're going X
plus the the previous answer which is
adding them together and then we're just
applying a layer Norm to this
cool if you want to look up more into
what layer Norm does and everything and
why it's so useful
you can totally go out of your way to do
that but uh layer Norm is essentially
just going to help smoothen out our
features here
so
we have this and honestly there's not
much else to that we just return this
final value here and that's pretty much
the output of our blocks so next up I'm
going to add a new little code block
here which is going to be
our feed forward so let's go ahead and
do that so feet forward just going to
look exactly like this it's actually
quite simple
so all we do is we make an nn.sequential
torch.nn we make this a sequential
network of linear linear relu and then
linear
so
in our linear we have to pay attention
to the shapes here so we have n embed
and then an embed times four and then
the really will just essentially what
the relay will do is it looks it looks
like this how many let me illustrate
this for you guys
so essentially you have this graph here
and
let's just make this a whole plane
actually
so
all of these values that are below zero
all these values that are below zero on
the x-axis and equal to zero will be
changed just to zero like that so you
have all these values that look like
this and then everything that is above
zero just stays the same so you
essentially just have this funny looking
shape it's like straight and then
diagonal that's what the relief function
does it looks at a number sees if it's
equal to or less than zero if that's
true we give that number zero and if
it's not then we just leave the number
alone so cool very uh cool non-linearity
function
you can read papers on that if you'd
like but
essentially the the shape of this just
doesn't matter all we're doing is we're
just making sure that we're just
converting some values if they're equal
to or below zero that's all this is
doing
and then
we essentially are multiplying
this we're doing this linear
transformation times this one so we have
to make sure that these inner we have to
make sure that these inner Dimensions
line up so four times n in bed and four
times n in bed those are equal to each
other so our output shape should be an
embed by an embed cool so now we have
our Dropout and in case you don't know
what Dropout is it pretty much just
makes a certain percentage of our
neurons just drop out and become zero
this is used to prevent overfitting and
some other little details that I'm sure
you could you could figure out through
experimenting
so all this actually looks like in a
parameter form is just a drop out
oh
chop out equals we'll just say 0.2 for
the same
so 0.2 means 20 percent or 0.2 is going
to yeah so 0.2 in percentage form is
just going to drop out at 20 of our
neurons turn them to zero to prevent
overfitting that's what that's doing
so cool we have our feed forward Network
we drop out after to prevent overfitting
and then we just call it Forward on this
sequential Network so cool feed forward
pretty self-explanatory let's jump into
the next piece we're going to add the
multi-head attention class so we built
all these decoder blocks we've built
inside of the decoder blocks we built
the feed forward and our res connections
and now
all we have to do left in this block is
the multi-head attention so it's going
to look exactly like this here we're
going to ignore the keys and queries for
now and save this for DOT product
attention
so we're gonna yeah essentially just
make a bunch of these
multiple heads and we're going to
concatening results into a linear
transformation so what does this look
like in code
well let's go ahead and add this here
all that attention cool it's a multiple
hedge of attention in parallel I
explained this earlier so not going to
jump into too much detail on that but we
have our knit we have our forward and
what are we doing in here so our
self.heads is just a module list and
modulus is kind of funky I'll dive into
it a little bit later but essential
we're doing is we're having a bunch of
these heads essentially in parallel for
each head so num heads let's say our num
heads is set to
uh
our num heads is set to maybe four in
this block we do multi-head attention we
do n heads and then head size so and
heads and then head side so numb heads
essentially what it is so for the number
of heads that we have which is four
uh we're gonna pretty much make
one-headed running in parallel so four
heads running in parallel is what this
does here
uh then we have this projection which is
essentially just going to project the uh
head size times the number of uh times
the number of heads to a an embed and
you might ask well that's weird because
uh numb heads times this is literally
equal to an embedding if you go back to
the math we did here
and the purpose of this is just to be
super hackable so that if you actually
do want to change these around it won't
be throwing your dimensionality errors
so that's what we're doing it's just a
little projection from our
uh whatever these values are up to this
constant feature length of an embed
so then we just follow that with a drop
out dropping out 20 of the Network's
neurons
now let's go into this forward here so
forward
torch doc concatenate or torch.cast and
we do 4H in self.heads so we're going to
concatenate each head together along the
last Dimension and the last dimension in
this case is the
be a batch by Time by we just say
feature Dimension or Channel dimension
uh the channel Dimension here is the
last one so we're going to concatenate
along this feature dimension
and let me just help you illustrate what
exactly this looks like so
when we concatenate along these we have
this B by T
and then we'll just say
uh
our features are going to be
H1 like our each of our heads here
another H1 H1 H1 these are all just
features of head one
and then our next would be H2
H2 H2 H2 then if let's just say we have
a third head go H3 H3
H3 H3 like that so we have
maybe four features per head and there's
three heads so essentially all we're
doing when we do this concatenate is
we're just concatenating these along the
last Dimension so to convert this like
ugly list format of just each head
features sequentially in order
uh which is like really hard to process
we're just concatenating these so
they're easier to process
so that's what that does
and then we just follow this with a
Dropout so we do our self brought
self.projection
and then just follow that with a drop
out so cool uh if that didn't totally
make sense you can totally just plug
this code into chat gbt and get a
detailed explanation on how it works if
something wasn't particularly clear but
essentially that's the premise you have
your batch by time buy or batch by
sequence sequence length or time use
interchangeably and then you have your
features which are all just in this
weird list format of each feature just
listed after another
so cool
that's what Malta head attention looks
like let's go ahead and Implement dot
product attention or scale dot product
attention so a little something I'd like
to cover before we go into our next
scaled dot product detention was just
this linear transformation here and you
might think well what's the point if
we're just transforming an embed to an
embed right that it's just kind of weird
to have them match like that and
essentially what this does is it just
adds in another learnable parameter for
us so it has a weight and a bias if we
set bias to false
like that then it wouldn't have a bias
but
it does have a bias so another just W X
plus b if you will a weight times X plus
a bias
so it just adds more learnable
parameters to help our Network learn
more about this text so cool I'm going
to go ahead and add in this last but not
least
scaled dot product attention or head
class
so there's going to be
a bunch of these heads hence class head
running in parallel and inside of here
we're going to do some scale dot product
attention so there's a lot of code in
here don't get too overwhelmed by this
but I'm going to walk through this step
by step so we have our init we have our
forward awesome
so what do we do in our
architecture here
so we have a key a query and a value
the keys and the queries dot product
together they get Scaled by
one over the square root of length of a
row in the keys or queries Matrix so
we'll just say maybe keys for example
the row of keys the the length of a row
and keys
and then we just do our masking to make
sure the network does not look ahead and
cheat
and then we do a soft Max and a matrix
multiply to essentially add this value
weight on top of it
so cool
we do this key or keep in mind this
initialization is not actually doing any
calculations but just rather
initializing the linear Transformations
that we will do in the forward pass
so the self.key is just going to
transform and embed head size bias false
and then I mean the rest of these are
just the same and in bed to head size
because each head will have 96 features
rather than 384 so we kind of already
went over that but that's just what
that's doing
cool that's just a linear transformation
that's happening to convert from 384 to
96 features
then we have this self.register buffer
well what does this do you might ask
register buffer is essentially just
going to register this no lookahead
masking in the model state so instead
having to re-initialize this every
single head for every single forward and
backward pass
we're just going to add this to the
model state so it's going to save us a
lot of computation that way on our
training so our training time is going
to be reduced just because we're
registering this
yeah so it's just going to prevent some
of that overhead computation of having
to redo this over and over again
you could still do training without this
it would just take longer
so that's what that's doing
yeah so now we have this drop out of
course and then in our forward pass
let's let's break this down step by step
here so I have a b by T by C so batch by
Time by Channel
is our shape
we just unpack those numbers and then we
have a key which is I'm just calling
this linear transformation here on an
input X
and then a query which is also calling
the same transformation but a different
learnable transformation on X as well
so what we get is this instead of B by T
by C we get B by T by head size hence
this transformation from through 384 to
96.
so that's what that is on this that's
how these turn out here
so now we can actually compute the
attention scores
so what do we do we'll just say way
we'll just say weights is our attention
weights are uh yeah I guess you could
say that we have our queries
dot product Matrix multiply with the
keys transposed so
what are this what does this actually
look like and I want to help I want to
help you guys sort of understand what
transposing does here
so let's go back to here and draw out
what this is going to look like
so
essentially what transposing is going to
do is
it is just going to make sure let me
draw this out first
so let's say you had
I don't know maybe
a well
B
see
and you have a
C
Andy cool let's draw some lines to
separate these
foreign
so essentially what this does is the the
transposing puts it into this form so if
we didn't have Tran uh transpose then
this would be in a different order it
wouldn't be a b c d in both uh from like
top to bottom left to right type of
thing it would be in a different order
which would essentially not allow us to
multiply them the same way so when we do
a by a a times B it's like sort of a
direct multiply if you will I don't know
if you remember times tables at all from
elementary school but that's pretty much
what it is we're just setting up in a
times table form and we're Computing
attention scores that way
so that's what that is that's what this
transposing is do is doing and all this
does is it just flips the second last
Dimension with the last dimension so in
our case our second last is T and our
last is head size so it just swaps these
two so we get B by T by head size and
then B by head size by T we dot product
these together
also keeping in mind our scaling here
which is taking this uh
we're just taking this scaling of
1 over the square root of length of a
row in the Keys
if we look at this here now there's a
little analogy I'd like to provide for
this scaling right here
so imagine a room with a group of people
and you're trying to understand the
overall conversation if everyone is
talking at once it might be challenging
to keep track of what's being said it
would be more manageable if you could
focus on one person at a time right
so that's similar to how a Malta had a
tension in a Transformer works so each
of these heads
divides the original problem of
understanding the entire conversation
I.E the entire input sequence into
smaller more manageable sub problems
each of these sub problems is a head so
the head size is the number of these sub
problems
now consider what happens when each
person talks louder or quieter if
someone if someone speaks too loudly or
the values and the vectors are very
large it might drown out the others this
could make it difficult to understand
the conversation because you're only
hearing One Voice or most of one voice
to prevent this we want to control how
loud or how quiet each person is talking
so we can hear everyone evenly the dot
product of the query and key vectors in
the attention mechanism is like how loud
each of voices if the vectors are very
large or high dimensional or many people
are talking the dot product can be very
large
to control this volume by scaling down
the dot product using the square root of
the head size
this scaling helps ensure that no single
voice is too dominant allowing us to
hear all the voices evenly this is why
we don't scale by the number of heads or
the number of time steps they don't
directly affect how loud each voice is
so In Sum multi-head attention allows us
to focus on different parts of the
conversation and scaling helps us to
hear all parts of the conversation
evenly allowing us to understand the
overall conversation better so hopefully
that helps you understand exactly what
this scaling is doing so now let's go
into the rest of this here
so we have this scaling applied for our
head size or yeah our head size
dimension
uh
we're doing this dot product matrix
multiplication here we get our B by T by
T and then what is this Mass filled mask
filled doing so let me help you
illustrate this here
so mask fill is essentially like we'll
take just uh we'll take we'll say block
size is three here right so we have
initially let's say we have a
uh like a one a 0.6 and then like a 0.4
okay
then our next one is
uh yeah we'll just say all of these are
the same okay
so
essentially in our first one we want to
mask out everything except everything
except for the first time step and then
when we advance one
so let's just change this your rack to
zero
when we go on to the next time step we
want to expose the next piece so 0.6 I
believe it was and then it's zero again
and then when we expose the next time
step after that we want to expose all of
them so just kind of what this means is
as we uh as the time step advances in
this sort of I guess vertical part is
every time this steps one we just want
to expose one more token or one more
of these values sort of in like a
staircase format
so essentially what this Mass fill is
doing is it's making this T by T So
block size by block size and for each of
these values we're going to set them to
negative Infinity so for each value
that's zero we're going to make that the
float value negative Infinity so it's
going to look like this
negative Infinity
negative Infinity just like that so
essentially what happens after this is
our softmax is going to take these
values and it's going to exponentiate
normalize them we already went over the
soft soft Max previously but essentially
what this is going to do this uh this
last Dimension here concatenates or not
concatenate rather apply the softmax
along the last dimension
is it's going to do that in this sort of
horizontal here so this last uh this
last T it's like blocks it's like block
size by block size so it's like we'll
say T1 and T2 each of these being length
of block size we're just going to do it
to this last T2 here and this horizontal
is T2 so hopefully that makes sense and
essentially
what this exponentiation is going to do
is it's going to turn these values to
zero
and this one is obviously going to
remain a one and then it's going to turn
these
into zero and it's going to probably
sharpen this one here so this one is
going to be more significant it's going
to grow more than the 0.6 because we're
exponentiating and then same here so
this one is going to be very very sharp
compared to 0.6 or 0.4
so that's what the softmax does
essentially the point of the softmax
function is to make the values stand out
more it's to make the model more
confident in highlighting attention
scores so when you have one value that's
like very big but not too big not
exploding because of our scaling right
we want to keep in mind our scaling but
when a value is Big when a score or
attention score is very big we want the
model to put a lot of focus on that and
to say this this is very important in
the entire sentence or the entire thing
of tokens and we just wanted to learn
the most from that
so essentially that's what softmax is
doing instead of just normal
normalizing mechanism it's just doing
some exponentiation to that to make the
model more confident in its predictions
so this will help us score better in the
long run if we just highlight what
tokens and what attention scores are
more important in the sequence
and then after this uh softmax here we
just apply a simple Dropout on this way
variable this new uh
this new calculated way scale dot
product tension uh masked and then
softmaxed we apply a Dropout on that
and then we perform our final weighted
aggregation so this V
multiplied by the output of the softmax
cool so we get this V self.value of X so
we just multiply that
a little pointer I wanted to add to this
module list which is yeah module list
here and then our order to go
yes our sequential Network here so we
have this sequential number of blocks
here for n layers and we have our module
list so what really is the difference
here
well modulus is not the same as
any.sequential in terms of the asterisk
usage that we see
uh in the language model class modulus
doesn't run one layer or head after
another but rather each is isolated and
gets its own unique perspective
sequential processing is where one block
depends on another to synchronously
complete so that means we're waiting on
one to finish before we move on to the
next so they're not completing
asynchronously or in parallel so the
multiple heads in a Transformer model
operate independently and their
computations can be processed in
parallel however this parallel
parallelism isn't due to the module list
that stores the heads
instead it's because of how the
computation are structured to take
advantage of the gpu's capabilities for
simultaneous computation
and this is also how the Deep learning
framework Pi torch interface interfaces
with the GPU so this isn't particularly
something we have to worry about too
much but you could supposedly think that
these are sort of running in parallel
um yeah so if you want to get into
Hardware then that's that's like your
whole realm there but this is pi torch
this is software not Hardware at all I
don't expect you have to have any
hardware knowledge about GPU CPUs
anything like that so anyways that's
just kind of a background on what's
going on there so cool uh
so let's actually go over what is going
on from the ground up here
so we have this GPT language model we
get our token embeddings positional
embeddings we have these sequential
blocks initialize our weights
for each of these blocks we have a this
this class block so we get a head size
parameter which is an embedded 384
divided by n heads which is four so we
get 96 from that that's the number of
features we're capturing self attention
we do a feed forward two layer Norms so
we go self attention layer Norm feed
forward
learn on
in the post Norm architecture
then we do a feed forward just a linear
followed by a relive followed by a
linear and then dropping that out
and then we have our multi-head
attention which just sort of structured
these attention heads running in
parallel and then concatenates the
results and then for each of these heads
we have our keys queries and values we
register a model state to prevent
overhead computation excessively
then we just do our scale data dot
product attention in this line we do our
Mast build to prevent look ahead we do
our soft Max to make our values sharper
and to make some of them stand out
and then we do a drop out finally on
that and just some weighted aggregation
we do our weights or this this final uh
this final weight variable multiplied by
our
weighted value from this
from this initially this linear
transformation so cool that's what's
happening step by step in this gbt
architecture amazing give yourself a
good pat on the back go grab some coffee
do whatever you need to do even get some
sleep and uh get ready for the next
section this is gonna be pretty fun so
there's actually another hyper parameter
I forgot to add which is end layer
and end layer is essential we'll say
equal to four and layer is essentially
equal to
the number of decoder blocks we have
so instead of like n block we just say n
layers it doesn't really matter what it
what it's called but that's what it
means and then number of heads is how
many heads we have running theoretically
in parallel and then an embed is the
number of total dimensions we want to
capture from all the heads concatenated
together type of thing we already went
over that so cool
hyper parameters block size sequence
length batch size is how many of these
do we want at the same time Max itters
is just training how many iterations we
want to do
learning rate is what we covered that in
actually the Desmos calculator that I
showed a little while back just showing
how
how we update the model weights based on
the derivative of the loss function
and then a valid errors which was just
reporting the loss and then
uh lastly the Dropout which is dropping
out 0.2 or 20 percent of the total
neurons
so awesome
that's pretty cool let's go ahead and
jump into some data stuff
so I'm going to pull out a paper here so
let's just make sure that everything
works here and then we're actually going
to download our data so I want to try to
run some iterations and
just make sure that our actually I made
some changes uh
pretty much this was this was weird and
didn't work so I just changed this
around to making our characters empty
opening this text file uh opening it
storing it in a variable with utf-8
format
and then uh just making our vocab this
sorted list set of our text
and then just making the vocab size the
length of that so let's go ahead and
actually run this through and I did
change the block size to 64 batch size
128 some other hyped parameters here
so honestly the block size and batch
size will depend on your
computational resources so
just experiment with these I'm just
going to try these out first just to
show you guys what this looks like
okay so it looks like we're getting idx
is not defined or could that be
okay yep so this is yeah so we could
just change that it's just saying idx is
not defined we're using index here idx
there so that should work down
and we're getting a local variable T
reference before assignment Okay so
we have some well we have t here and
then we initialize T there so let's just
bring that up
to there cool now let's try and run this
oh
shape is invalid for input size of okay
let's see what we got so it turns out we
don't actually need two token embedding
tables a little bit of a selling mistake
but we don't need two of those so I'll
just delete that
and then
what I'm going to do is go ahead and run
this again I'll see a new error local
variable T references for assignment
okay so our T is our T is referenced
here and well how can we initialize this
what we can do is we could take this
index here of shape B by T because it
goes B by T plus one Etc and just keeps
growing
so we can actually unpack that so we
could go B
B and T is going to be index dot shape
just unpack that
so cool
so now we're going to run this training
oop
and it looks like it's working so far
so that's amazing
super cool Step Zero train last 4.4
that's actually a pretty good training
loss overall so uh we'll come back after
this is done I've set it to train for uh
I've set it to train for 3000 iterations
printing every 500 iterations so we'll
just see the lock the loss six times
over this entire training process
or we should
and why it's going to a hundred
eval editors
okay
estimate loss is
okay so we don't actually need eval
interval
I get rid of that
I'll just make this
sure why not 100 we'll keep that
and it's just going to keep going here
we'll see our loss over time is
hopefully going to get smaller so I'll
come back when that's done as for the
data we're going to be using the open
webs Text corpus and
let's just go down here
so this is the this is a paper called
survey
survey of large language Models All
right so I'll just go back to open
web text
whatever that is up
it's just fine because okay
so open webtext this is consisted of a
bunch of Reddit links or just Reddit
upvotes so if you go on Reddit and you
see a bunch of those
posts that are highly upvoted or
downvoted they're pretty much those
pieces of text are valuable and they
contain things that we can train them
so pretty much webtext is just a corpus
of all these voted links but it's not
publicly available so somebody created
an open source version called open
webtext hence open
and it's pretty much just an open
version of this so we're going to
download that there's a bunch of other
corpora here like common crawl which is
really really big so like petabyte scale
data volume
you have a bunch of books you know so
that this is a good paper to read over
it's just called uh
a survey of large language models you
can search this up and it'll come up you
could just download the PDF for it so
this is a really nice paper read over
that if you'd like but anyways this is a
download link for this open webtext
Corpus so just go to this link I have it
in the GitHub repo
and you just go to download
I'm going to bring you to this drive so
you can go ahead and right click this
and just hit download it'll say 12
gigabytes exceeds maximum file size that
it can scan so it's like this might have
a virus don't worry it doesn't have a
virus this is actually created by a
researcher so not really bad people are
in charge of creating text corpora so go
ahead and download anyway
I've actually already downloaded this so
uh
yeah I'll come back
when our training is actually done here
so I'm actually going to stop here
iteration 2000 because
we're not actually getting that much
amazing progress and the reason for this
is because our hyper parameters so batch
size and block size I mean these are
okay but what you might want to change
up is our learning rate so some
combinations of learning rights that are
really useful is like
uh three three to the negative three it
goes uh three e to the negative 4. you
go one e to the negative three one e
one e to the negative four so these are
all learning rates that I like to play
around with uh these are just sort of
common ones it's up to you if you want
to use them or not but
uh what I might do actually is just
downgrade to three to the negative 4.
and we'll retest it
as well I'm gonna bump up the
uh the number of heads and the number of
layers
so that we can capture more complex
relationships in the text thus having it
learn more
so I'm going to change each of these to
eight
I've got eight
I'm gonna go
actually kernel will go
uh restart
now we'll just run this from the top
and we'll run that
cool
so let's see what we actually start off
with and what our loss looks like over
time
cool so we got step one 4.5 about the
same as last time it's like point two
off or something so it's pretty close
all right let's see the next iteration
here
that's wonderful so before we were
getting like 3.1 ish or something around
that range 3.15 now we're getting 2.2 so
you can see that as we change hyper
parameters we can actually see a
significant change in our loss so
uh this is amazing this is just to sort
of prove how cool hyper parameters are
and what they do for you so
uh given that let's uh let's start
changing around some data stuff so this
is this right here is The Wizard of Oz
text just a simple text file it's the
it's the size isn't super large so we
can actually open it all into RAM at
once
but if we were to use the open web text
we cannot actually read you know 45
gigabytes of utf-8 text in Ram at once
just can't do that unless you have like
maybe 64 or 128 gigabytes of RAM this is
really just not feasible at all so
uh we're gonna do some data
pre-processing here some data cleaning
and then just a way to Simply load data
into the GPT so let's go ahead and do
that so the model has actually gotten
really good at predicting the next token
as you can see uh the train loss here is
1.01 so let's actually
find uh what the prediction accuracy of
that is so I might just go into gpt4
here
and
just ask it uh
what is the prediction
accuracy of
loss 1.01
the loss value comes with a loss
function during the printing process
okay so let's
cross entropy loss doesn't mean the
model is 99 accurate
okay
so that pretty much means that the model
is really accurate but I want to find a
value here so if the
we'll go to Wolfram Alpha
and just we'll just guess some values
here so negative Ln of let's say
0.9
okay so probably not that
0.3
0.2
.4
0.35 yep so the model has about a 35
chance of guessing the next token as of
right now so that's actually pretty good
so one in every three tokens are spot on
so that is wonderful this is converging
even more we're getting 0.89 so now it's
getting like every
like 40 percent are being guessed
properly our validation is not doing
amazing though uh but we'll we'll Linger
on that a little bit here and you'll see
some sort of how this changes as we
scale our data
but uh yeah so I've installed this
webtext dot tar file files are
interesting so in order to actually
extract these you simply just right
click on them you go extract to and then
it'll just make a new file here so it'll
process this you have to make sure you
have WinRAR or else this might not work
to the fullest extent and yeah
so we'll just wait for this to finish up
here should end up with something that
looks like this
so open webtext and inside of here you
have a bunch of XZ files cool so there's
actually 20 000 of these so we're gonna
do a lot of uh it's gonna definitely
there's definitely gonna be some for
Loops in here for sure
so
let's just handle this step by step in
this data extract file so
first off we're going to need to import
some python modules we're going to use
OS for interacting with the operating
system lzma
for handling XZ files which are type of
compressed file like 7-Zip for example
and then
tqdm for displaying a progress bar so
you see a progress bar but left to right
in the in the terminal and that's pretty
much going to show us how quick we are
uh that's executing the script
so next up
we're going to define a function called
XE files in dur that takes a directory
as an input returns a list of all of the
XC file names
in that directory it's going to use OS
dot Lister to get all the file names and
Os path is file
OS path is file to check if each one is
a file and not a directory or symbolic
link
if a file name ends with DOT XC and it's
a file it'll be added to the list so we
just have a bunch of these files uh
each element is just the title of each
file in there so that's pretty much what
that does
then next up here
we'll set up some variables folder path
it's just going to be where our XE files
are located so I'm actually going to
change this here because that's like an
incorrect file path but
yes
just like that
you have to make sure that these slashes
are actually forward slashes or else you
might get bytecode errors so when it
actually tries to read the string it it
doesn't think that these are separated
or the the backwards lashes do like
weird things um so you could either do
like a one forward slash or two back rib
slashes and that should work
so awesome just make sure you have
forward slashes and you should be good
the folder path is where all these files
are located all these XC files are
located as you saw
output file is the pattern for output
file names in case we want to have more
than one of them so if you want to have
200 output files instead of one then
it'll just be like output 0 up of one
output two Etc
and then a vocab file is where we want
to save our vocabulary keep in mind in
this giant Corpus you can't push it on
to Ram it once so what we're going to do
is as we're reading these little
compressed files 20 000 of them we're
going to take all of the new characters
from them and just push them into some
vocab file containing all of the
different characters that we have
so that way we can handle this later and
just pretty much sort it into some list
containing all of our vocabulary
split files how many files you want to
split this into so
pretty much this it ties back to Output
file and just these these curly braces
here how many do we want to have if we
want to have more than one then we would
this would take effect
so cool
now we'll use our
X-Files indoor to get a list of file
names and store them in this variable
we'll count the number of total XC files
simply the length of our file names
now in here
we'll calculate the number of files to
process for each output file if the user
is requested more than one output file
to request more than one output file
this is the total number of files
divided by the number
output files rounded down
so if the user only wants one output
file Max count is the same as total
files and
that's how that works so
next up we'll just create a set to store
a vocabulary when we start appending
these new characters into it
a set is a collection of unique items in
case you did not know entirely what a
set was
now this is where it gets interesting
now we're ready to process our DOT XZ
files for each output file process Max
count files
for each file will open it read its
contents and write the contents of the
current output file
and then add any unique characters to
our vocabulary set
after processing Max count files remove
them from our list of files
then finally
open
finally we're right all of our
vocabulary to this file so we pretty
much just open uh yeah we just write all
of these characters in the vocab to this
vocab file which is here vocab.txt
so awesome
now
um honestly we could we could just go
ahead and run this so
let's go ahead and go in here I'm going
to go CLS to clear that
we'll go python
data extract.pi let's see this work it's
magic
how many files would you like to split
this into we'll go one
then we get a progress bar 20 000 files
and we'll just let that load I'll come
back to you in about 30 minutes to check
up on this okay so there's another
little one thing we want to consider for
and it's actually quite important is our
splits so our train and vow splits uh we
it would be really inefficient to just
get blocks and then creating you know
train and bow splits as we go every new
batch we get
so in turn well we might be better off
doing is just creating a train an output
train file and an output file file so
just two of them instead of one
train is 90 of our data Bala is 10 of
our data if that makes sense
so pretty much what I did is I took away
that little input line for how many
files do you want
as you can see I got quite a bit of
files produced here
by not doing that correctly so don't do
that
and
yeah essentially we're just we're pretty
much just doing that so we're processing
some training files we're separating
ninety percent of the names on the left
side and then 10 of the names on the
right side we're just separating those
into two different arrays file names and
then we're just processing each of those
array space on the file names
so I took away that little bit that was
asking you know how many how many of
those how many files per split do you
want so I took that away and this is
like effectively the same code just a
little bit of tweaks
and yeah so I'm gonna go ahead and run
this
data extract
cool
so we've got an output train and then
after this it's going to do the output
validation set so I'll come back after
this is done so awesome I have just
downloaded uh both or I've both got both
these splits output train and valve
train so just to confirm that they're
actually the right size got 38.9
and then 4.27 so if we do this divided
by 9 so about 30 38.9 divided by 9. we
have 4.32 and it's pretty close to 4.27
so we can confirm that these are pretty
much the uh the link that we expect them
to be
so awesome we have this vocab.txt file
wonderful so now we have to focus on is
getting this into our batches so when we
call our get batch function actually CD
out of this open this in a Jupiter
notebook
just copy my desktop
and over here
and perfect
so it was open when web text folder with
these files awesome
and our GPT V1
so this get batch function is going to
have to change
also these aren't going to have to
change as well and this one too these
are probably not going to be here
um but pretty much let's go ahead and
first of all get this vocab.txt in so
what I'm going to do is I'm just going
to go
we're going to go open webtext slash
vocab
dot txt cool so that's our vocab right
there text read vocab size the length of
that nice
so that's what our vocab is
and then
what we're going to do next is change
this get batch function around
so first of all I'm going to go ahead
and get rid of this here get rid of that
data
and then
I've actually produced some code
specifically for this so I'm just going
to go back to my
I'm going to find this folder
okay
so I've actually produced some code here
I produce this off camera but
uh pretty much what this is going to do
it's going to let us call a split okay
so we have our get batch function all of
this down here is the same as our gptv1
file
and then does it data is just going to
get a random chunk of text so a giant
block of text
and
the way that we get it is actually
pretty interesting so the way that we
get this text is something called memory
mapping so memory mapping is a way to
look at disk files or to open them and
look at pieces of them without opening
the entire thing at once so memory
mapping look at I'm not a hardware guy
so I can't really talk about that but
uh yeah memory mapping is pretty cool
and allows us to look at little chunks
at a time in very large text files so
that's essentially what we're doing here
we pass in the split
split
file name is equal to transplant this is
this is just an example text file
if the split is equal to train then this
is our file name else file split
and then we're going to open this file
name in binary mode this has to be in
binary mode
it's also a lot more efficient in binary
mode
and then we're going to open this with a
mem map so I don't expect you to
memorize all the memapp syntax you can
look at the docs if you would like but
I'm just going to explain sort of
logically what's happening so we're
going to open this with the memory map
Library
and we're going to open this as mm so
the file size is literally just the
length of it so determining the file
size and all we're doing from this point
is we're just finding a position so
we're using the random Library
and we're finding a position between
0 and the file size minus block size
times batch size so pretty much we have
this giant uh this giant text file we
could either what we want to do is we
want to start from zero and go up to
like just before the end because if we
actually sample that last piece then
it's still going to have some wiggle
room to reach further into the file if
we just made it from like
the first uh like the very start of the
file to the very end
then I would want to do is it would want
to look past the end because it would
want to look at more tokens from that
and then we would just get errors
because you can't read more than the
file size if that makes sense so that's
why I'm just making this little
threshold here and uh
yeah that's what that does that's the
starting position it could be a random
number between the start and a little
bit a little margin from the end here
so
next up we have this seek function so
seek is going to go to the start
position and then block
is going to read
we're going to go up to the start
position so it's going to seek up to
there that's where it's going to start
it's going to go up to it and then the
read function is going to find a block
of text that is block size times batch
size so it's going to find a little
snippet of text in there at the starting
position and it's going to be of size
it's going to have this the same amount
of I guess bytes as block size time
times batch size then all of that minus
one just so that it fits into this start
position we don't get errors here that's
why I put the minus one
but
yes we'll get a pretty we'll get a
pretty decent uh
text amount I guess you could say it's
going to be enough to work with you
could you could of course increase this
if you wanted to you could do like you
know times eight if you wanted like
times eight and then times eight up here
but we're not going to do that uh based
on my experience this has performed
pretty well so we're going to stick with
this method here
and then
uh we just decode this bit of text the
reason we decode it is it's it's because
it's uh we read it in binary form so
once we have this block of text we
actually have to decode this to UFA
format or utf-8 format and then any like
byte code errors we get we're just going
to ignore that this is something you
learned through practice is when you
start dealing with like really weird
data or if it has like Corruptions in it
you'll get errors so all you want to do
is all this does is it pretty much says
okay we're just going to ignore this bit
of text and we're just going to sample
everything around it and not include
that part and plus since we're doing so
many iterations it won't actually
interfere that much so we should be all
right and then for this replace little
function here I was noticing I got
errors about this slash R so all this
does is it just replaces that with an
empty string and then finally we have
all this uh we have all this decoded
data so all we're going to do is just
encode this into the tokenized form so
it's all in it's all in the tokenized
form uh integers or torch.longs data
type
and we just that that's what our data is
instead of a bunch of characters it's
just a bunch of uh numbers and then we
return that into our get batch
and this is what our data is so that's
pretty cool we can get either train or
valve split and
that's sort of what it looks like in
practice that's how we sample from very
large text files at a smaller scale bit
by bit so
let's go ahead and implement this here
I'm gonna go grab this entire thing
and pop over to here
I'm just going to replace that
so get random chunk get batch
cool so now we can actually go ahead and
perhaps run this actually before we run
this there's a little something we need
to add in here
so
I have this transplant.txt and a
valsplit.txt so I just need to change
these
so let's go rename will go
uh transplant.txt
and then uh valvesplit.txt cool
and then we could just go open web text
forward slash
and then
same thing for here
cool let's go ahead and run this now
and we're getting errors mem map is not
defined okay so that's another thing we
need to probably uh add in then
so I'm actually just gonna
stop this process from running here
we're gonna go pip
install
mem map
oh
my map is not defined oh we don't
actually need to install this it by
default comes with the operating system
so
what we actually need to do
is let me just close this
GPT V1
awesome is everything everything is good
nothing is broken sweet
so what I actually need to do up here is
import this so I need to go
uh Imports that map just like that
and
should be good to start running the
script
and random is not defined again another
importation we have to make
import
random
and we should start seeing some progress
going here so once we see the first
iteration I'm going to stop it come back
at the last iteration and then we'll
start adding some little bits and pieces
onto our script here to make it better
so we're already about 600 iterations in
and you can see how the training loss is
actually done really well so far it's
gone from 10.5 drop all the way to 2.38
and
we can actually see that we might be
able to actually get a vowel loss that
is lower than the train because keep in
mind in train mode uh the Dropout takes
effect but in val in eval mode
uh let me just scroll up to this here
yes so model.eval what this does is it
turns off the Dropout so
we don't we don't lose any of the
neurons and they're all sort of showing
the same features and giving all the
information they're supposed to because
they're all active but in train mode 20
of them are off so once you actually see
an e-file mode it does better
that means that the network has started
to
form a sense of completeness in its
learning so it's just adjusting things a
little bit once it hits that point and
we might see this happen momentarily but
this is really good progress so far a
loss of 1.8 is amazing
so uh yeah in the meantime I'm just
going to add some some little tweaks
here and there to improve this script so
I've actually stopped the iteration
process but we've gone to 700 steps and
we can already see that vowel loss is
becoming a less than train loss which is
showing that the model is actually
converging and doing very well so this
architecture is amazing we've pretty
much we've pretty much covered every
architectural masks Pi torch part that
this script has to offer
uh the only thing I want to add are
actually a few things I want to add one
of them being
torch.load and torch.save so
one thing that's going to be really
important when you start to scale up
your your iterations is you don't just
want to run a script that executes you
know a training loop with an
architecture and that's it you want to
have some way to store those learnable
parameters so that's what torch.load and
torch.save does
uh
so I have some file right and you can
pretty much
you could put it into like a serialized
format when you save it you take your
initial architecture in our case it
would actually be the GPT language model
so you would save this because it
contains everything all these other
classes as well they're all inside of
GPT language model it would save that
architecture and you'd essentially
serialize it into some pickled file that
would have the file extension.pkl
so
essentially instead of using torch we're
just going to use a library called
pickle because they're essentially the
same thing pickle is pickles a little
bit easier to use or at least a little
bit easier to understand there's less
there's less to it pickle will only work
on one GPU so if you have like eight
gpus at the same time you're going to
want to learn a little bit more about
Hardware stuff and some Pi torch docs
but
pretty much if we want to save this
after training what we're going to do is
we're going to use
a little Library called pickle and this
comes pre-installed with Windows
um one type of Windows import pickle
okay
so we want to do is implement this after
the training loop after all these param
parameters have been updated and learned
to the fullest extent
so after this training loop we're simply
going to open we're going to do with
open and we could just go model zero
zero one like that
and then
uh just that dot pkl is the file
extension for it
and then since we're writing to it we're
going to go right binary
as f
and then in order to actually save this
we just go pickle dot dump
and then we can use uh model and then
just F like that
so
if I start recording this it's going to
make if I start recording this training
process it's going to make my
it's going to make my clip lag so I'm
going to come back to this after we've
done uh let's just say about 100
iterations we're going to do 100 editors
and I'm going to come back and show you
guys uh what the model file looks like
what I actually did is I changed some of
the model hyper parameters because I was
taking way too long to perform what we
wanted it to so I changed and had to one
and layer to one and I half batch size
all the way down from 64 to 32.
so what I'm actually going to add here
is just to make sure I just want to I
like to print this out at the beginning
Sprint device
make sure that the device is Cuda
let's go back down so it did in fact
train the model so we got all this done
uh
and yeah so I don't know why I did 2.54
or whatever that that was just the
entire loss okay
so
model saved awesome what does this
actually look like here so this model
Dot pkl 106 megabytes isn't that
wonderful
so this is our model file this is what
they look like so it's just a serialized
uh pretty much the entire architecture
all the parameters of the model the
state everything that it contains and we
just compress that into a little pkl
file take that out you can press it and
then just use it again with all those
same parameters so
awesome and all this really took was
uh we just open as this we do a pickle
dot dump and then just to make sure that
I actually save I just like to add a
little prince name in there cool
so next what I'd like to add is a little
weight for us to
uh instead of just doing all of our
training at lunch and then saving the
model being able to train multiple times
so I'm going to go up here
up to our
GPT language model here
and
let's just see what I'm going to do
I'm gonna go with open
and we're gonna go
uh model zero one pkl
and we're gonna go read binary so I'm
actually going to read it we're gonna
we're gonna load this into our script
here
so
I'm gonna I'm gonna go as f
and then uh I believe it's pickle dot
load
you can just go yeah
model equals pickle.load and then we'll
just
essentially if we bump that right in
there
they'll print
uh
loading
model parameters
Dot
and then just put F in there
and then once it is loaded we'll do
print
load it
successfully
cool so I'm actually going to try this
out now go
do that
boom
and boom
so
loading model parameters loaded
successfully
and we'll actually see this start to
work on its own now so
is it going to begin or is it not going
to begin
let's run that okay perfect
so now we should take the loss that we
had before which was about 2.54 I
believe something around those something
along those lines you can see that our
training process is greatly accelerated
so we had 100 now it's just going to do
an estimate loss
cool
and we're almost done
1.96 awesome and the model saved so
essentially what we can do with this is
we can now save models and then we can
load them and then iterate further so if
you wanted to
you could create a super cool uh GPT
language model script here and you could
essentially give it like ten thousand or
Twenty Thousand iterations to run
overnight you'd be able to save it and
then import that into say a chat bot if
you want so that's pretty cool and
that's just kind of a a good good thing
good little it's kind of essential for
language modeling because
what are what's the point in having a
machine learning model if you can't
actually use it and deploy it so you
need to save for this stuff to work
all right now let's move on to
a little something in this task manager
here which I'd like to go over so this
shared GPU memory here
and is dedicated GPU memory so dedicated
means how much uh vram video RAM
does your GPU actually have on the card
so on the card it's going to be very
it's going to be very quick memory
because it's it doesn't have to the
electrons don't have to travel as
quickly that's that's kind of the logic
of it the electrons don't have to trap
they don't have to travel as far
because
um the little Ram chip is right there
so to get a dedicated GPU memories a lot
faster share GPU memory is essentially
if this gets overloaded it'll use some
of the RAM on your computer instead
so this will typically be about half of
your computer's Ram I have 32 gigabytes
of RAM on my computer so 16.0 makes
sense half 32. and yeah so you want to
make sure you're only using dedicated
GPU memory uh having having your shared
GPU memory go up is not usually a good
thing a little bit is fine but
uh dedicated GPU memory is the fastest
and you want everything to stick on
there just try to make sure all of your
parameters sort of fit around this uh
whatever your Max Capacity is maybe it's
four maybe it's eight maybe it's 48. who
knows
and a good way to figure out what the
highest amount of ram you can use on
your GPU without it getting memory
errors or using shared memory is to
actually play around
with these parameters up here
so
uh block size and batch size
actually let me switch those around
these are not supposed to be in that
order but
all good
like our batch size
64. it's 128 okay
so
batch size and block size are very big
contributors to how much memory you're
going to use learning rate is not Max
iterations is not evaluators is not but
these three will so these are the amount
of features that you store the amount of
heads you have running in parallel
and then also n layers so some of these
will not affect you as much because
they're more sort of restrained to
computation how quickly you can do
operations if something is sequential
uh so n like end layer won't strain you
as much as something like batch and
block size
but those are just good little things to
sort of tweak and play around with so I
found the optimal sort of set of hyper
parameters for my PC and that happens to
be eight eight three eighty four uh
learning rights stays the same and then
64 128 for this so that happened to be
the optimal hyper parameters for my
computer it'll probably be different for
yours if you don't have eight gigabytes
of RAM on your GPU
so anyways
um that's a little something you have to
pay attention to to make sure you don't
run out of errors and a technique you
can use which I'm not actually going to
show you in this course but it's quite
useful it's something called Auto tuning
and while Auto tuning does is it pretty
much runs a bunch of these uh a bunch of
models with different sets of hyper
parameters so it'll run like a batch
size 64 batch size 32 batch size 16
batch size maybe 256. it'll be like okay
which ones are throwing errors and which
ones aren't
so what it'll do if you have if you
properly if you properly set up an auto
tuning script is
you will be able to find the most
optimal set of parameters for your
computer
most optimal set of hyper parameters
that is possible
so our tuning is cool you could
definitely look more into that there's
tons of research on it and yeah so Auto
tuning is cool let's dig into the next
part the next little cool trick we use
in practice especially by Machine
learning Engineers it's a little
something called arguments so you pass
an argument into not necessarily a
function but into the command line so
this is what it'll look like this is
just a basic example of what Arc parsing
will look like so there's a scope python
uh art parsing because that's a script's
name I go Dash
uh llms because that's what it says
right here this is what the argument is
and then we can just pass in a string
let's say hello
the provided
whatever is hello so cool you can add
little arguments to this and I'm even
going to change this around
could say
uh
Bap size and then
we'll just go like that
batch
batch size
please
provide
a batch size
I can do the same thing again
and see it says
phone arguments required are batch size
So that obviously didn't work and if we
actually try it the correct way
our parsing.py then we go Dash
batch size
we can make it 32.
oh
that's because it's not a string
so
what we need to actually do is it's BS
somewhere okay
so
args
ARS args
so we need to change this
to BS like that and we can go batch size
is 32. okay
so even I'm a little bit new to
arguments as well but
this is something that comes in very
handy when you're trying to you know
each time you're trying to change some
some parameters uh if you add you know
new GPU or whatever and you're like oh I
want to double my batch size it's like
sure you can easily do that so a lot of
the times it won't just have one but
you'll have like many meaning like maybe
a dozen or so of these uh of these
little arguments so
uh that is what this looks like and
we're going to go ahead and implement
this into our little script here so
uh
I'm just going to pop over to GPT one
I'm going to pull this up on my second
monitor here
and
uh in terms of you know these I'm just
gonna
I'm just gonna start off by
making a
importation ARG
uh Arc parser
or Arc parse rather that's what it's
called and then
we go parser is equal to I'll just
I'll just copy and paste this entire
thing and why not
cool
okay
so
let me get a batch size or something
and then
uh we'll add in the second part here so
args parse the arguments here
uh
and the little scope
batch size like that our batch size is
equal to whatever that was
and we'll just go args dots
Arc stop batch size so cool
um
this
and not defined oh yes so I got a little
not defined thing here and pretty much
all I missed was that we returned this
so essentially uh this should be equal
to this right here so I'm just gonna go
ahead and copy that
and
uh boot parse arcs
except we don't have a parse arcs
function
so
what do we need to do instead well it
actually that might just work on its own
let's try it out
okay so it looks like uh it's actually
expecting some input here in code
so that's probably working and if we if
we ported this into a script then it
would simply ask us for some input so I
believe we're doing this correctly let's
go ahead
and actually switch over and pour all of
this into some code so I'm going to make
a training file and a chat file so the
training file is going to be all of our
parameters whatever all of our
architecture and then the actual
training Loop itself we're gonna have
some arguments in there and then the
chat bot is going to be pretty much just
a question answer thing that just
reproduces text so we'll just be like
prompt completion type of thing and yeah
so let's go ahead and Implement that
here
so in our
GPT course here I'm going to go
training.py
and we're going to go
app.py just like that
so in training let's go ahead and drag
everything in here
I'm just going to move this over to the
second screen and just copy and paste uh
everything in in order here
so next up we have our characters
and then we have our tokenizer
and then our get random chunk and get
batches
Street our estimate loss function
and then this giant piece of code
containing most of the architecture we
built up
I'm just going to add that in there
cool we're not getting any warnings
and then the training Loop
and the optimizer awesome
then after this uh we would simply have
this context but the point of this is
that we want to have this in our chatbot
script
so what I'm going to do is in this
training.py
I'm going to keep all of these the same
I'm going to keep this entire thing the
same get rid of this little block of
code
and we're going to go into
the uh chat bot here
so loading model parameters good we want
to load some in train some more and then
dump it chatbot is not going to dump
anything it's just going to save so I'm
going to take all of our training here
and instead of dumping take that away
we'll also take away the
training loop as well
okay I don't believe we have anything
else to actually bring in
we don't need our get batch we do not
need our get random chunks
so awesome we're just importing these
parameters
I default like that
awesome
so
from this point we have imported
uh We've imported our model cool so
let's go ahead and port in our little uh
chat bot here this little end piece
which is going to allow us to
essentially chat with the model so this
is what it looks like a little while
loop uh we have a prompt we just input
something uh prompt next line I should
be fairly self-explanatory and we have
this tensor we're going to encode this
prompt into a bunch of integers or
torch.long data types on the GPU where
devices Cuda
uh and then after after we've actually
generated these so model.generate we're
going to unsqueeze these remember it's a
torch.tensor so it's going to be in the
matrices form so it's going to look like
this it's going to be uh
it's going to look like this or whatever
like uh that's essentially what the
shape is so all we're doing when we
unsqueeze it is we're just taking away
this wrapping around it
so awesome
and then we're just doing Max your
tokens for example 150 here and then uh
to a list format and then we can just
print these out as January characters
awesome so it's just going to ask us
prompt and then do some compute give us
a completion so on so forth so that's
what this is doing here and another
thing I wanted to point out is actually
when we load these parameters in at
least on training uh it's going to
initially give us errors if we don't
have a model to load it from we're going
to get errors from that because the
model will just not be anything and we
won't be able to import stuff so that's
going to give you errors first of all
another thing you want to pay attention
to is to make sure that when you
actually trained this initial model that
it matches all of the architectural
stuff and the hyper parameters that you
used that when you're you're using to
load up again so
when you're running your forward pass
and whatnot you just want to make sure
that this architecture sort of lines up
with it just so that you don't get any
architectural errors those can be really
confusing to debug
so yeah uh and the way we can do this is
actually just commenting it out here
so awesome we're able to save load
models
and
are able to use a little Loop to create
a sort of chap up that's not really
helpful
because we haven't trained it an insane
amount on data that actually is useful
so another little detail that's very
important is to actually make sure that
you have any module in all of these
classes and subclasses and in dot module
basically works as a tracker for all of
your parameters it makes make sure that
all of your and extensions run correctly
and just overall a Cornerstone for pi
torch like you need it so make sure you
have any module in all these classes I
know that block sort of comes out of GPT
language model and so on so forth but
just all of these classes with NN or any
learnable parameters you will need it in
it's overall just a good practice to
have and in module in all of your
classes overall just to sort of avoid
those errors so cool
uh I didn't explicitly go over that at
the beginning but that's just a heads up
you always want to make sure any modules
inside of these so
cool
now uh something I'd like to highlight
is a little error that we get when we
try to generate when we have Max new
tokens above block size so let me show
you that right now so you just go python
chat bot then batch size 32.
so we could say
uh you could say hello for example
okay so it's going to give us some
errors here and what exactly does this
error mean well when we try to generate
150 new tokens what it's doing is it's
taking the previous you know
h-e-l-l-o exclamation mark six tokens
and it's pretty much adding up 150 on
top of that so we have 156 tokens that
we're now trying to fit inside of block
size which in our case is
128. so of course
156 does not fit into 128. and that's
why we get some errors here so
all we have to do is make sure that uh
we essentially
what we could do is make sure that Max
new tokens is small enough and then be
sort of paying attention when we make
prompts or we could actually make a
little cropping
cropping tool here so what this will do
is it'll pretty much crop to the last
block size tokens
and this is super useful because it it
pretty much doesn't make us have to pay
attention to maximum tokens all the time
and it just essentially crops it around
that 128 limit so I'm going to go ahead
and replace index here with index con or
index condition
and we go ahead and run this again
so I could say hello
and we get a successful completion
awesome we can keep asking new prompts I
could just type
and awesome so yeah we're not really
getting any of these uh dimensioning
dimensionality like architecture fitting
type errors if you want to call them if
you want to make it super fancy that way
but yeah there's not really that much
else to do uh yeah there's a few points
I want to go over uh including fine
tuning so I'm going to go over a little
illustrative example as to what fine
tuning actually looks like in practice
so in pre-training which is what this
course is based off of in pre-training
you have this giant Text corpus right
you have this giant Corpus here
with some text in it
and essentially what you do is you take
out little Snippets
uh these are called
blocks or batches or chunks you could
say you take a little batch of the
batches of these you sample random
little blocks and you take multiple
batches of them
and you essentially have this let's just
say
h e l l o
and maybe the next predict maybe the
outputs are the or the targets rather or
uh
e-l-l-o exclamation mark so it's just
shifted over by one and so given this
given this uh sequence of characters you
want to predict this which is just the
input shifted by one that's what
pre-training is
and keep in mind that these are the same
size this is one two three four and five
same thing here these are both five
characters long
fine tuning however is not completely
the same so I could have
hello
and then maybe like a question mark
and it would respond you know
the model might respond
l r
U
maybe that's just a response that it
gives us we can obviously see that hello
does not have the same amount of
characters but the same amount of
indices as how are you
so
this is essentially the difference
between fine tuning and pre-training
with fine tuning you just have to add a
little bit of different things in your
generate function to compensate for not
having the same amount of indices in
your inputs and targets and rather just
generate until you receive an end token
so what they don't explicitly say here
is at the end of this uh question
there's actually a little n token which
we usually do it usually looks like this
so go
like that or
like this these are these are end tokens
and then you typically have the same for
start tokens like an s
or
start like that pretty simple and
essentially you would just you would
just append them
and
and a start token the start token
doesn't matter as much because we
essentially just are looking at what
this does and then we start generating
the start doesn't really matter because
we don't really need to know when to
start generating it just happens but the
end token is important because we don't
want to just generate an infinite number
of tokens right because these aren't the
same size it could theoretically
generate a really really long completion
so all we want to make sure is that it's
not generating an infinite amount of
tokens consuming infinite amount of
computation
and just to prevent that Loop so that's
why we append this end token to the end
here instead of this
set up this little end bit
and essentially once this end token is
sampled you would end the generation
simple as that
and we don't actually sample from the
token itself but rather the actual uh
the I guess you could say index or the
the numerical value the encoded version
of End which is usually just going to be
the length of your vocab size
uh plus one
so if you're a vocab size for in our
case is like maybe 32 000 your end token
would be at index thirty two thousand
and one so that way when you Sample When
You sample an end token
when you sample that 32 000 and one
token
uh you actually just end the sequence
and of course when you train when you
train your model you're always appending
this n token to the end so you get your
initial inputs and then inside of either
your training data or when you actually
are processing it and feeding it into
that Transformer you have some sort of
function that's just appending that
little uh thirty two thousand and one
token index to it so that's pretty much
what fine tuning is that's sums up fine
tuning and the whole process of creating
these giant language models is to of
course help people and there's no better
way to do that than to
literally have all the information that
humans have ever known meaning like
common crawl or open webtext or
Wikipedia and even research papers
pre-training on all of that so just
doing again the same size and then shift
over for targets
and then after you've iterated on that
many many times you switch over to
fine-tuning where you have these uh
specifically picked out prompt and
completion Pairs and you just train on
those for a really long time until you
are satisfied with your result and yeah
that's what language modeling is there
are a few key planners I want to leave
you with before you head on your way to
research and development and machine
learning so
first things first there's a little
something called efficiency testing or
just finding out how quickly certain
operations takes we'll just call this
efficiency testing and I'll show you
exactly how to do this right here
efficiency
yeah I don't know if I spelled that
correctly I don't know why it's doing
that okay uh anyways
we'll just pop into code here
and
essentially we'll just do
we'll do
I'm testing
go import time
and essentially uh all we're going to do
is just we're just going to time how
long operations take so uh and here you
can go
I don't know and you can go start time
equals time dot time and essentially
what this function does is it just takes
a look at the current time right now the
current like millisecond very precise
and we can do some little operation like
I don't know four I and range
uh we'll just go
ten thousand
oh
print I
sample or print I times two okay and
then we can just end the time here so go
end time
equals time.time again calling the
current times we're doing right now
versus back then and that little
difference is how long it took to
execute so all we can do is just do we
can say total time you want we can say
total time equals end time
minus start time ammo scope print
uh end time or
I'm taken
let's go total
total time like that just execute this
python
time testing
cool time taken 1.32 seconds so you can
essentially time every single operation
you do with this method and you can see
even in your I encourage you to actually
try this out I'm not going to but I
encourage you to try out how long the
model actually takes to do certain
things like how long does it take to
load a model how does it take to save a
model how long does it take to estimate
the loss right
play around with Hyper parameters see
how long things take and maybe you'll
figure out something new who knows but
this is a little something we use to
pretty much test how long something
takes how efficient it is and then to
also see if it's worth investigating a
new way of approaching something in case
it takes ridiculous amount of time
so
that's time testing and efficiency
testing for you the next little bit I
want to cover is the history I'm not
going to go over the entire history of
AI and llms but essentially
we originated with something called rnns
okay rnns are called recurrent neural
networks and
they're really inefficient at least for
scaled AI systems so rnns are a little
essentially think of it as little Loop
keeps learning and learning and this is
sequential right it does this and then
this and then this then this has to wait
for each completion it's synchronous you
can't have multiple of them at once
because they're complex gpus cannot run
complex things they're only designed for
just just matrix multiplication and very
simple path like that so rnns are
essentially a little bit dumber than
Transformers and they are run on the CPU
so rnns was where we last sort of
stopped at and what I encourage you to
do is look into more of the language
modeling and AI history and research
that has led up to this point so you can
have an idea as to how researchers have
been able to quickly innovate given all
these historical Innovations so you have
like all these things leading up to the
Transformer well how did they all fill
off a size philosophize up to that point
and yeah it's it's just something good
to sort of be confident in is innovating
as both a researcher and engineer and a
business person
so cool
rnns were where we where we sort of
finished off and now it's Transformers
and gpts that's the current state of AI
next up I would like to go over
something called quantization so
quantization is essentially a way to
reduce the memory usage by your
parameters so there's actually a paper
here called Q Laura efficient
fine-tuning of quan quantized llms so
all this does in simple form is it
pretty much instead of using 32-bit
floating Point numbers it goes not only
to 16 bit of half Precision but all the
way down to four
so what this actually looks like is in
binary code or in byte code
it will look somewhere here
some array
of numbers that it uses
okay I can't find it but pretty much
what it is is it is a bunch of it's a
bunch of floating Point numbers
and they're all between negative one and
one and there are 16 of them
if you have a four bit number that means
it can hold 16 different values 0
through 15 which is 16 values and all
you pretty much do is you have this
array of floating Point numbers you use
the bytecode of that
of that 4-bit number to look up the
index in that array and that is your
weight
that is the weight they use in your
model
so this way instead of using 32-bit and
just having a super long numbers that
are like super precise you can have
super precise numbers that are just
generally good parameters to have that
just perform decently they're just sort
of well spread out and experimented on
and they just they happen to work and
you have 16 of them instead of you know
a lot
so that's a that's another cool little
thing that's going on right now is a
four bit quantizations it's a little bit
harder to implement uh I would encourage
you to experiment with half Precision
meaning 16-bit floating Point numbers so
that means it occupies uh 16 on and off
switches or capacitors on your GPU
and yeah so quantization is cool to sort
of scale down the memory so that way you
can scale up all of your hyper
parameters and have a more complex model
with these uh
just essentially to have bigger models
with less space
take it up
so that is quantization
and this is the paper for it this is a
little link you can search up if you
want to get more familiar with this see
sort of performance standards and
whatnot
the next thing I'd like to cover is
gradient accumulation so you might have
heard of this you might not have heard
of this gradient accumulation will
Ascend a gradient accumulation does is
it will accumulate a gradient over say
we just set a variable X so every X
iterations it'll just accumulate those
iterations average them
and what this allows you to do is
instead of
updating each iteration you're updating
every X iterations so that allows you to
fit more parameters and more info and
more generalization into this one piece
so that way when you
uh update your parameters it's able to
generalize more over maybe a higher
batch size or a higher block size
so when you distribute this over
many iterations and average them you can
fit more into each iteration because
it's sort of calculating all of them
combined so yeah that's a cool little
trick you can use if your GPU maybe
isn't as big if it doesn't have as much
vram on it
so granite and accumulation is wonderful
and it's used Lots in practice
the final thing I'd like to leave you
guys off with is something called
hugging face and you've probably heard a
lot a lot about this so far but let me
just guide you through and show you how
absolutely explosive hugging faces for
machine learning so you have a bunch of
models data sets spaces talks Etc
and
let's just go to models for example
so let's just showcase how cool this is
we have multimodal AIS which could be
like
image and text or video Etc right you
have multiple different modes so it's
not just text or not just video it's
many different ones at the same time so
you have multimodal models you have
computer vision
you have natural language processing and
we're do we're actually doing natural
language processing in this course
we have audio
a tabular and reinforcement learning so
this is really cool and you can actually
just download these models and host them
on your own computer so that is really
cool
you also have data sets which are even
cooler
and these are pretty much just really
high quality data sets of prompt and
answer completions at least for our
purpose if you want to use those so you
have
uh question answering or conversational
so if I go to the open Orca data set for
example as 9 000 downloads 500 likes
it has a bunch of
IDS system prompts so you're an AI
assistant whatever and then you have the
cool stuff which is you will be given a
definition of a task version and some
input of the task Etc and then the
response it's like oh
we just give it an input and ask it to
answer in a format and actually did that
correctly so
you could pretty much train these on a
bunch of
prompts that you would be able to feed
into gpt4 and try to make your model
perform that way and this actually has
4.23 million rows in the training split
which is amazing
so
data sets are wonderful and you can find
the best ones at least the best
fine-tuning data sets on open Orca
really good
as for pre-training uh I believe I
mentioned this earlier in this survey
survey of large language models paper
that let me just go down through Reddit
links
yep so you could use like open web text
you could use common crawl you could use
books you could use Wikipedia these are
all pre-training data sources so yeah
hopefully that leaves you with a better
understanding on how to create gpts
Transformers and pretty good large
language models from scratch with your
own data that you scraped or that you
downloaded
and yeah
that's it thanks for watching so you've
learned a ton in this course about
language modeling how to use data how to
create architectures from scratch maybe
even how to look at research papers
so if you really enjoy this content I
would encourage you to maybe subscribe
and like on my YouTube channel which is
in the description I make many videos
about AI programming and computer
science in general so you could totally
feel free to subscribe there if you
don't want to subscribe that's fine uh
you can always unsubscribe later if you
want to it's completely free
but yeah I also have a GitHub repo in
the description for all the code that we
used not the data because it's way too
big but all of the code and The Wizard
of Oz Wizard of Oz text file so
that is on the GitHub repo in the
description thanks for watching